as you walk down the halls of the SCP
Foundation site 19 speaking in the
various windows at the anomalies
contained there you might catch a
glimpse of a dark figure bent over a
table tinkering away like an artisan in
his Workshop a vintage black Apothecary
bag sits next to him open and if you
stop and watch for a while you'll see
him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an IV stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly Focus singularly on his craft
whatever that might be only one thing
could distract him from his efforts you
he feels your Gaze on him and he looks
up dark eyes glittering from behind a
beaked ceramic mask he reminds you of an
illustration you once saw in a book
about the Black Death the gear the
plague doctors wore while treating
patients on their deathbeds hello he
greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkled beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear fellow are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand and you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
hell I can examine you he offers Palm
press flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work
table back and forth listening to the
sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morgue
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden away pieces
of the corpses tissue samples and jars
of formaldehyde he could pull out when
the monotony became too much with the
days of fresh materials of enlightened
discourse with other men and women of
science were over how he missed those
days the chance to work with others as
he once had what had he done wrong all
he did was treat the sick sure they
didn't always understand their illness
didn't want to receive their medicine
but that wasn't a choice for the patient
to make that should have been up to the
physician perhaps they didn't trust his
expertise then see how his work served
the greater good like those who watched
Jonas Salk invent the polio vaccine or
Louis Pasteur with milk of bacteria they
were confused by the advanced scientific
practices and feared that which they did
not understand he could forgive them for
their ignorance he was magnanimous that
way if only they would let him out of
this infernal room he could prove his
work's Worth to them he could cure them
all begin a new era of wellness and
peace worldwide he didn't exactly sleep
but when he rested on his little cot in
the corner of the room he dreamed of
that future of a world healed by a style
a knock at the door stirred him from his
reverie someone someone was at the door
of his containment cell he glanced at
the little window and saw a guard there
with a tray of food he greeted the man
with an enthusiastic wave
sustenance he didn't require the food
for survival of course but it helped his
mind work more efficiently it reminded
him of a time before these fluorescent
lights and these same Four Walls of
crusty bread with fresh butter by the
banks of the Sun a little slot opened in
the door and the tray was shoved through
there was bread just as he hoped a small
dish of butter pot of jam and a cup of
tea still seeming he picked up the cup
at first taking a deep breath ah an
herbal blend with fresh lavender lovely
he couldn't see the guard through the
window anymore but he called out to him
just the same thank you for the
Libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he
could have gotten a better look at the
man seen the power of His complexion a
Tremor in his hand he thought he had
spotted sweat beating on his forehead
could he be ill the case required
further examination to be certain he
sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him
why must they scream at the sight of his
efforts flee from his instruments it
didn't seem fair still the pursuit of
science rarely was a glamorous one he
had learned as much over the centuries
one day though history would look back
on him kindly of this he could be
certain he was just settling in and
beginning to spread butter across the
admittedly stale bread when a horrible
sound shook him to attention he had
heard the noise before though he had
never seen its source it was an
ear-splitting scream a whale of pure
Agony like the sound of a wounded wild
animal he had heard many many screams
during his life from patients and those
who stood in the way of his work but
until he had been brought into custody
of the foundation he had never heard a
scream quite like this one it was pure
rage Devastation and suffering mixed
together wet with tears and loud enough
to rip through human vocal holds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain of
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thought of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the Halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beat nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire heard the gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darning past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as Flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he studied himself and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
Damage Done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
Chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open well
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood Stark and Vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely Pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet here save for
one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to
the wall was a pale thin figure it
shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs this poor soul was clearly in great
distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white distended arms
wrapped around itself as a cried excuse
me the doctor cried out to the pitiful
creature are you all right do you need
assistance he didn't answer it just
continued to cry had something so
despondent been responsible for this
destruction the dozens of corpses the
smashed in walls the crumbled doors and
shattered Windows it seemed impossible
sure it was large and looked strong but
he had never seen a monster cry before
this couldn't be a dangerous creature
not when it was so sad he would help it
but first he would attend to some of
these bodies he sat his bag on the
ground pulled out several vials of
liquid a set of syringes and a variety
of other surgical tools he might need
now after such a long Hiatus he could
resume his work in a meaningful way he
couldn't be certain how long he worked
Reviving these poor souls and
reconstructing their bodies as the pale
creature wept in the corner the sobbing
faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he
removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his Suffering
The Corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open an eyeball dangling unseen from
the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide
impossibly wide and a treat that same
terrible sound as before tears streamed
from its colorless eyes its arms shaking
with unbridled rage as its jaws locked
around the patient's head like a boa
construct in one fluid motion it
swallowed the revived man whole while
the doctor watched in shock he had been
wrong this was not an innocent creature
caught in the wrong place at the wrong
time this creature whatever it was was
deeply sick he had never seen such an
advanced aggressive case of the
pestilence it heard rumors of course but
never encountered it firsthand as a
doctor he had sworn to do no harm but in
a drastic situation drastic measures
have to be taken it was well known by
himself and the doctors at this
Foundation that he could cause any and
all biological functions in an organism
to cease with a single touch and so he
approached the creature arm outstretched
ready to administer that necessary touch
to protect the rest of his patients as
he approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of Tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a Breakneck speed I am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the Beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thud the doctor paced around the Fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still Rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious very curious
indeed he muttered perhaps there were
comorbidities present other infections
aside from the pestilence which rendered
the creature unnaturally strong
resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell it required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistance to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risked
his Discovery and subsequent
Interruption so it would have to suffice
first he set up an IV stand filled with
a vivid green liquid it was easy to find
a vein the creature's skin was nearly
translucent now that he could be certain
the creature would not wake during
surgery he could make the first incision
scalpel be held out of hand and his
favorite surgical blade was placed in it
by one of the helpful patients thank
he slid the scalpel along the hairline
of the creature or where the hairline
would be if it weren't completely bald
once the scalp was removed he set it
aside for later when it could be
reattached bone sub please he held out
his hand again and again his assistant
gave him the proper tool this however
was when things got strange the doctor
had always been a Deft hand at cutting
he'd once even received tutelage from
the great Robert Liston but no matter
how hard he tried to saw it never left a
scratch on the creature's skeleton
naturally this was somewhat frustrating
he wanted to study the creature's brain
tissue to get a sense for what was going
up there neurologically and he couldn't
do that if it was impossible to saw off
the creature's cranial cap he blunted
two of his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he'd learned while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
Egyptians you produce a long curved Hook
from his bag and insert it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes do all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place it was mid-stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me I am in surgery at the moment please
do not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or lower his
weapon in fact he shouted something into
the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into
the skull of the patient standing at his
side how dare you the doctor cried
readying himself to confront the guard
but it was too late dozens of other
guards were swarming the room and
neutralizing his assistance some in
hazmat suits grabbed his arms and pulled
him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he
fought or how loudly he protested then
something incredible happened something
wonderful the creature opened its eyes
and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one
another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared Placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing of Flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole I did it the doctor
shouted overcome with Elation I've cured
you now Begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive Containment
Breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards the staff agreed
not to tell scp-049 about any of this
better to just let him have this one he
really seemed like he needed a win
[Music]
foreign
some of the anomalies the SCP Foundation
deals with are dangerous with the most
powerful able to end all life and even
reality as we know it others pose no
threat at all and seem content to Simply
exist still others are something else
entirely
scp-4999 is a humanoid entity though its
appearance seems to fluctuate between
manifestations with the only unchanging
detail being that it always is dressed
in dark Formal Wear originally thought
by many to be an urban legend local
Tales of scp-4999 are what initially
tipped the foundation off to its
existence and further Research indicates
that there are accounts that may be
referring to the appearances of 49.99
throughout recorded history strangest of
all though is the consistency with which
it appears or rather the consistent
situations and types of people it
appears to from the data available it
seems that
scp-4999 only appears to people in a
very specific type of need as you'll see
see in the case of a subject named Alex
herrerford and the Fateful Knight he
experienced the road was slippery and
Alex was driving too fast he knew this
of course but it's a different matter
altogether to know a thing and to care
about it rain hammered on the front
windshield the weak headlights of his
2005 Honda Civic barely punching into
the thick black knight ahead of him
winding through the Mountainside the
road was mostly empty saved for the very
occasional twin beams of light blazing
past him due to his high speed it was
hard to hear the honking of angry horns
over the heavy pounding of the rain then
it happened in a way Alex knew it was
inevitable his tread worn Wheels finally
lost contact with the ground thick layer
of rain water between them and asphalt
betraying his speeding vehicle's grip on
the road and sending it careening out of
control he had expected fear but instead
felt nothing really a slight sense of
anticipation like wincing right before a
punched lands in that childhood game of
hitting each other on the arm it wasn't
that the world had slowed down but
perhaps his brain was simply working at
a much greater velocity now recognizing
its own impending death his speed of
thought seemed magnified to the point of
slowing his perception down he heard of
soldiers in war zones experiencing the
same phenomenon as they found sure that
in the next few seconds they'd be dead
Alex wondered would he smash into a tree
go off a Cliff's Edge you could hardly
see the forest or the terrain Beyond in
the thick rain in the dark of the
mountain though he traveled this road a
million times before he had no idea
where he actually
he supposed it wouldn't really matter
which it was as usual his thoughts
turned to her or rather they had simply
run their course and return to the one
place they always did it wasn't like
there were many other people to think
about in Alex's mostly empty life there
was and always had there since the
moment he'd met her mostly just her but
even Alex's heightened State of Mind
couldn't delay the inevitable for long
it would be a cliff after all Alex
thought curiously catching a glimpse of
town lights far away and below the
correspond 180 degrees out into empty
air Then Came Crashing Down with a
horrible Roar of shattered glass and
tearing metal as it tumbled down the
hillside even over the torrential
downpour the noise of Alex's crash was
significant had anyone been around to
hear it finally after over a hundred
feet down a steep incline the car
smashed into a single thick oak tree
bringing the disaster to an end as if On
Cue the rain began to let up slowly at
first then all of a sudden in that
peculiar way that Northwest torrential
downpours tend to do as if the sky had
at last finished emptying itself all at
once inside the shattered vehicle Alex
was incredibly alive at least for the
time being the airbag deployment had
spared his face the worst of it and the
sturdy aluminum frame of the vehicle had
given its all in protecting Alex's body
from the downhill crash but even
post-modern vehicle engineering had its
limits his breath came in slow ragged
gasps difficult at first but gradually
steady not an improvement in his
condition but rather his body dedicating
the rapidly dwindling resources at its
disposal into vital functions going as
long as possible opening his eyes ouch
was surprised to find himself right side
up less surprised to look down at the
shattered mess his Limbs and lower body
had become gradually Alex's thoughts
cleared his sense of self returning
after the bone jarring dropped down the
Steep incline and sudden stop at the end
looking to his right he could see the
trunk of the tree that had stopped his
out of control tumble despite himself
Alex laugh a weak gurgling chuckle so it
was the cliff and a tree after all he
focused on breathing letting the waves
of pain wash over him until his brain
eventually canceled them out by
injecting his broken body with
adrenaline and chemicals everything was
quiet and still after the crash and the
rain but to his surprise he could hear
something it was faint at first just a
soft crunch of footsteps on gravel but
the sound grew louder and louder until
at last it came to a stop outside Alex's
window with every ounce of effort Alex
turned his head towards the sound a
rescuer now impossible nobody was up on
this mountain and nobody could possibly
have reached him here so quickly even if
there had been he supposed he should
have been surprised yet almost from the
moment that his eyes fell on the tall
handsome figure with the Casual yet
fashionably cut black suit Alex accepted
him for what he was there was no shock
no confusion for the second time tonight
just a calm sense of acceptance the man
probably somewhere in his mid-30s leaned
down to peer in through the window he
said nothing as he casually observed the
extent of Alex's injuries satisfied he
laid a hand on Alex's shoulder the grip
was firm but not painfully so just
strong enough to communicate I am here
with you things will be all right after
a slight squeeze the figure reached
inside his jacket and produced a pack of
cigarettes packing the tobacco with
swift Taps against his palm before
removing two cigarettes and offering one
to Alex Alex nodded his hat a very small
motion that exploded pain across his
shattered body no thank you but that
stuff will kill you Alex smiled the man
paused for a moment the ghost of a smile
showing on his face for just a moment
before disappearing returning the
offered cigarette the man took his own
and lit it giving Alex a good look at
his face in the light of his cigarette
lighter Alex had been right the man
appeared to be somewhere in his mid to
late 30s handsome but not cover model so
just pleasing to the eyes he sported
short hair carefully combed and
perfectly knee completely unaffected by
the slight drizzle that still fell the
more Alex looked at him though the less
he could remember about the man's exact
features wasn't that they changed in any
way but rather that he simply couldn't
hold on to any details for more than a
few seconds I'm dying aren't I the
figure didn't speak nor did it nod or
make any form of verbal or bodily
communication he simply looked and Alex
understood Alex had never been
particularly religious or spiritual but
in that luck he understood that there
was a world Beyond and one that he would
very quickly be entering into it was as
if for the first time in his life he was
able to probe that world reality peeling
away just enough to Glimpse what was
beyond twisting paths through planes of
Shadow and light both shuffling figures
along each and at the very center of it
all a light now a feeling love pulsing
forth like the Beating Heart of it all
the saints had their Angels the wicked
their demons but everyone else in
between the two they had him a guide
someone to watch over them on their
final Journey Alex coughed it was ending
soon the man took a drag from his
cigarette and removed a handkerchief
from another hidden Pocket carefully
dabbing away the blood around Alex's
chin then returned to his silent smoking
his vision was beginning to dim around
the edges the the noises of the forest
growing more and more distant Alex knew
it wouldn't be long now but he had just
one final thing to do as he always knew
they would his thoughts returned to her
here at the end once more he turned his
head towards the passenger side sea pain
exploding across his body with the
motion there just on the far edge of the
seat as his phone having miraculously
survived the crash it was no good though
even if he'd been able to move his
shattered right arm he could never reach
it with his fading strength the smoking
man took one final pull of his cigarette
putting it out on the side of the
vehicle and pocketing the stump then he
reached through the broken driver's side
window Alex catching a slight whiff of
cigarette smoke blended with an
unrecognizable but Pleasant cologne the
man reached across Alex and grabbed the
phone pulling back and looking down at
Alex's shattered right hand after a
moment he reached down once more and put
the phone in Alex's left hand thank you
the words were barely a whisper he had
to concentrate now willing the pressing
Darkness to part just long enough for
one final task the man once more placed
his hand reassuringly on Alex's shoulder
and the Darkness parted slightly just
enough for what Alex needed to do he
worked the phone awkwardly with his left
hand gritting his teeth through the pain
of broken fingers opening a new message
he scrolled down his contacts G H I J
finally K he found her name at last then
began typing out a message I still think
about you every time it rains he moved
his thumb to press send but that's when
Alex's body failed him at last the phone
tumbling out of his glass but the man
was there to catch it moving blindly
fast he snatched the falling phone up
and held it carefully to Alex's eyes
before pressing send he held the phone
there for Alex to see through his fading
Vision until at last message sent
confirmed successful delivery the rain
began once more temperamental as it
always is in the Pacific Northwest fat
heavy raindrops fell on the scene of a
terrible accident the victims seemingly
having died on impact on his lap though
lay his phone and somewhere far away and
Far Below this dark Mountainside a
message notification chirped on a
distant phone
scp-4999 manifests to only one person at
a time and only when they are alone all
subjects to date have been in the final
stages of a terminal illness suffering
from a life-threatening injury or
otherwise on their deathbed it also
appears that all subjects have
personalities and lives that could be
described as non-descript insignificant
or otherwise unremarkable no testing of
scp-4999 has been authorized by the
foundation due to both the difficulty in
predicting where it will appear as well
as the fact that observation seems to
prevent the anomaly from appearing there
are also ethical concerns since many in
the foundation feel that scp-4999 is
providing an important service to
humanity even if it is only for those on
the margins of society and it is debated
whether this should be one anomalous
creature that is allowed to continue its
existence and its work without
interference
scp-2000 is an unremarkable location it
is an old rarely used Park Ranger
Station in Yellowstone National Park
it's in the middle of nowhere and it
gets deliveries of supplies from
helicopters and unmarked cars as needed
while a few civilians have attempted to
break in none have been successful and
scp-2000 remains undisturbed kept in
plain sight without anything seemingly
important about it but why is this one
the most secure locations in SCP history
why is it of the utmost importance that
it continue to exist no matter what the
answer May rest in a mysterious document
found in the most unlikely of locations
the Marianas Trench is the deepest point
on Earth and the SCP Foundation has made
many trips there to investigate strange
phenomena but what they recovered on one
visit exposed one of the most closely
guarded secrets in Foundation history it
was a document that had somehow survived
at the bottom of the ocean sealed in a
pipe and coated in wax to keep it
airtight and waterproof it appeared that
it had been packaged in such a way that
it could survive anything and that's
exactly what its Rider wanted she wasn't
sure when the world had begun to end but
she could see it coming for a while she
looked out her window and saw all the
signs the Seas were getting colder and
less hospitable to life the air was
getting warmer every year resources were
dwindling and the population was
increasing tensions were rising and
while no one knew just when it would
come almost everyone seems sure that the
world or at least Humanity would reach
its conclusion soon it was a sinking
ship that first really made it clear
things were going in the wrong direction
the Disney Magic was one of the world's
most popular cruise ships a favorite
vacation destination for families it was
also one of the most carefully built
ships as the company prided itself on
safety and had learned well from past
cruise ship tragedies so the world was
rightfully shocked when one day it was
announced that the ship had sunk while
pulling into Port no one knew what had
happened and there was something even
more mysterious about this tragedy no
one seemed to have any footage of the
sinking despite round-the-clock news
coverage all the pictures were of the
ships still afloat that is until the
news companies received a tape the
networks were so eager to play the
footage that none of them reviewed it
first and the footage went straight to
air it showed the ship moving along
smoothly surrounded by smaller boats
when it suddenly stopped it was as if it
had been frozen in place and the footage
showed people on the deck of the ship
falling over from the abrupt stop
everything went silent and then an odd
foam emerged from behind the boat
everyone assumed it was the engine
having issues but it wasn't the engine
it was a massive arm at least a hundred
feet long and belonging to an Eldritch
being just below the surface it reached
up grabbed the boat and ripped it open
like a piece of tissue paper the
thousands of people on board ran for
safety but there was nowhere they could
go jet zoomed overhead ready to attack
whatever the thing in the water was a
massive spiny figure started rearing up
out of the water and then the video when
playing the letter found in the Marianas
Trench continued to explain what
happened next the president quickly
declared a state state of emergency and
implored everyone to stay calm
television networks were placed under
government control and were only allowed
to broadcast government-sanctioned
information it wasn't long before the
internet became restricted too with
people prohibited from sharing
information that wasn't authorized the
government just kept telling people to
stay calm and go about their lives the
writer of the letter tried to follow
this advice and went to work and paid
her bills as if life was still normal
but all around her she saw terrified
faces and they were right to be scared
this was only the start of the crisis
that would soon grip the entire world
more and more strange things started
happening but none of them were tied to
the mysterious monster that had been
seen emerging from the sea towns were
evacuated because of rioting or placed
under quarantine after an outbreak of a
mysterious disease destruction was
blamed on terrorist attacks or wildfires
The Writer's brother called her to tell
her that he had been forced out of his
the reason was supposedly a wildfire but
he had gotten a chance to look at the
fire as he was being evacuated there was
something odd about it he could swear he
saw a figure of a man in the fire a man
made of fire and he was moving
deliberately but she couldn't ask any
questions about what he had seen because
the call got dropped and she never got
to speak to her brother again it was
becoming harder and harder to get any
information about what was happening
with most news sources shut down or
under strict government control there
were only vague rumors for her to latch
onto people talked about zombies
ravaging the north about people who seem
normal one moment losing their minds and
going on killing sprees there were
Whispers of a doomsday cult rising up
that was trying to stem the apocalypse
through human sacrifices there was even
talk about the ground itself coming to
life and eating people it all sounded
like one thing the end of the world the
letters writer trying to stay sane
keeping her information intake to a
minimum and attempting to go about her
life in as normal away as she could but
it wouldn't be long before the horrors
outside came to find her and they became
impossible to ignore it was early in the
morning when she heard screaming and
gunshots outside she could smell
something burning and found blood
smeared on her window but she was too
scared to find out what was happening
she hid and waited for the noise to die
down soon the power and heating went out
and her water supply cut off not long
after she knew she would have to go
outside if she wanted to survive and she
wasn't prepared for what she would find
or rather what she wouldn't her house
was in a flat suburban area without any
major geographical landmarks so she
wasn't expecting to step outside and
find a massive Cliff with the other side
nowhere to be seen not only did it look
like the rest of the world had fallen
away but she couldn't see the bottom of
the cliff it was like that half of the
world no longer existed what was left of
her neighborhood had been torn apart
with blood and destruction everywhere
and she seemed to be the only person
left had she been saved because she hid
or had the others taken the opportunity
to evacuate she didn't know but all the
houses around her had been abandoned she
was determined to survive and so she
took what supplies she needed from the
empty homes and retreated back to her
own it soon became clear though that
much more had changed than just the
geography of the world time itself
seemed to be slowing down the sun Stood
Still In The Sky not moving from one
spot for days sometimes a heavy fog
would quickly roll in and render her
essentially blind but worst of all she
soon found that she was no longer alone
whatever had come into her neighborhood
now it wasn't human the first to come
were strange roughly man-sized metal
creatures then came smaller creatures
like the one that looked like a pill bug
but one the size of a cat this one
seemed harmless at first but then it
looked at her and screamed stop in a
human voice but this was nothing
compared to what came next giant
blimp-like maggots with hundreds of eyes
they were ferocious Predators landing
and eating anything inside she was sure
with all of these Horrors that she must
be the only human left but one day after
one of the disgusting blimps passed by
she found someone else he looked like he
belonged to a SWAT team and was clearly
hurt seeing another human was enough to
Spur her into action and she pulled him
to Safety in her home he told her that
he had been hunting one of the blimp
maggots she told him that he was the
first person she had seen since the
cliff showed up in her neighborhood and
the rest of the world had disappeared
his response to this was odd though he
told her that the world hadn't
disappeared it had simply relocated but
couldn't tell her any more than that she
pressed him for more information and he
said that his orders really meant
nothing anymore he revealed that he
worked for a foundation that Tracked
Down strange and dangerous creatures and
captured them for research and to keep
the world safe but something had gone
wrong all the entities they had been
keeping contained had broken free at the
same time it was too late to reverse the
damage and the world had been declared a
gh0 dead Greenhouse scenario the
foundation had failed but there was a
plan there were still people alive but
carefully contained around the world in
safe zones the foundation had a way to
reboot the world including recreating
people with all the memories intact the
foundation would clear out the dangerous
entities repair the damage and use their
technology to put everything back as it
was this world would be gone but it
would be replaced with another one that
resembled itself exactly with no
memories of the horrors that had
occurred this couldn't be done right it
was impossible to sweep all of this away
he just smiled and said why not it's
been done before she didn't know when
the end would come she didn't even know
she would realize it was happening but
she didn't want to be forgotten so she
wrote her thoughts down and sealed them
in a tube she sealed the tube and waxed
and waited maybe her house wouldn't be
fully destroyed maybe it would wind up
underwater as the man had briefly
mentioned maybe her message would endure
and be found one day as the last relic
of a world that had been wiped away she
wouldn't be around to see it but maybe
her world would be remembered the true
purpose of scp-2000 is the foundation's
most closely guarded secret a massive
underground facility designed to prevent
Humanity's Extinction able to produce a
hundred thousand humans per day it
contains memory banks that hold the
entire history of the human species and
all associated in from
but all documentation regarding its
initial construction and history has
been lost though no one is sure whether
this information was lost in one of the
resets or by Design the foundation has
made sure that scp-2000 will not be
breached the facility is guarded by
Cognito hazards that will stop anyone
without the appropriate inoculation any
unauthorized access attempts are
considered grounds for instant
termination regardless of how high
ranking someone might be in the
foundation
scp-2000 is to the foundation with the
svalbar global seed vault is to
agriculture the Fail-Safe in case
everything goes wrong that's why it has
the object class of thumbnail a rare
classification that is secret to all but
the highest levels of the foundation but
to almost everyone including every SCP
Foundation member who has never
encountered it
scp-2000 is just an old rarely used park
ranger station and Yellowstone National
Park with absolutely nothing unique
speak about it and no reason to look
closer and the foundation will ensures
it stays that way that's why when a
letter was found at the bottom of the
Mariana's Trench that described one of
these World resetting scenarios a letter
that pleads to not let the world that
existed before be forgotten or hidden
away the foundation made sure with
absolute certainty that it would never
see the light of day endless that's a
word you're likely to hear thrown around
a lot at the SCP Foundation like
scp-3008 known as the infinite Ikea
endless or take the life of The
Tragically Immortal Dr bright who became
one with scp-963 and now is condemned to
existing within it on some level forever
endless or most pertinent of all for
today's video take
scp-087 a terrifying staircase full of
tangible darkness and a frightening and
unknowable entity no matter how far down
and you go it seems as though there's
just another flight waiting for you
endless but really is anything ever
really endless or is endless just the
word we use for something when we
haven't found that sought after end just
yet for those who travel far enough
there may be a limit to the infinite
Ikea someday Dr Bright's Medallion one
day might lay a nerd and lifeless with
no traces of his Consciousness left and
for those who Venture down far enough
able to clench their teeth and get past
the fear you may someday find that even
scp-087 has a final flight but what if
this isn't just a hypothetical what if
this has already happened but the truth
was considered too dangerous or too
horrifying to share what's really at the
bottom of scp-087 today we hope to find
out let's just also hope that knowing
doesn't end up being more of a burden
than we'd expected before we head to the
bottom of the endless staircase though
Oh we must first return to scp-087's
file and refresh our memories on some of
the crucial Basics after all it's been
quite some time since our last video on
the subject this Euclid class anomaly is
one of the most well-known and feared
partially thanks to classified
information being leaked via certain
video game probably coded by the
Serpent's hand as we alluded to earlier
many know zero eight seven as the
endless staircase based in an
administrative building of a classified
North American University campus it's
been behind a number of mysterious
deaths and disappearances and has left
many of its escaping victims traumatized
and in a state of permanent Catatonia
having to descend the staircase is just
that terrifying equally Infamous as the
staircase itself are the three tests
that the foundation conducted into the
staircase before deciding to just board
up the door forever in the first a
d-class that was once a member of the
foundation was forced to see just how
many flights he could descend not long
after first entering the staircase and
beginning to make his way down he heard
the desperate and distressed pleas of a
child he kept descending but found he
seemed to be getting no closer to the
source of the distress when he was deep
enough that's when he encountered
scp-087-1 a frightening uncanny face
with few discernible features the sheer
Terror of encountering this entity was
enough to send him running back to the
top the second test played out similarly
with a d-class being sent in with a
number of powerful sticky backed lights
that he was ordered to place against the
walls as he descended this was done in
hopes of increasing visibility on the
staircase however it proved to be
unsuccessful has the darkness in 087 is
more of a tangible presence than the
mere absence of light it was able to
smother out visibility regardless of a
light's source of power once again the
d-class heard the crying and encountered
the face causing him to flee and the
third and penultimate test involved a
d-class who got really unlucky she
traversed the staircase deeper than any
of her predecessors before eventually
encountering the horrifying face of
scp-087-1 however rather than running up
and away from the entity in the state of
sheer Panic the d-class instead ran
downwards deeper and deeper into the
staircase the audio cut as the face
continued in its Pursuit and the d-class
was never seen again did you notice that
we said penultimate and not final before
that last one that's because there's
actually a highly classified fourth
Expedition into the scp-087 staircase
but as you can see on the original file
the data is expunged what could have
happened in that study that led the
foundation to wipe it from the records
did they discover the great secret
behind scp-087 a secret too horrible for
Mortal Minds to Bear we're not just
going to give you one unanswered today
we're going to give you three that's
right three different interpretations of
the secret fourth Expedition into
scp-087 which is the real one well
you'll just have to see after all
nothing is simple when it comes to
scp-087 though our first potential
option is the most simple of the three
in this iteration of the experiment a
male d-class murderer was instructed to
descend the staircase Into the Heart of
scp-087 with the foundation hoping to
find out what happened to D 9884 the
female d-class who disappeared at the
conclusion of the third expedition in a
sense this new d-class would discover
the Fate that most likely befell d-9884
but through first-hand experience rather
than distant observation being directed
by Dr erdio over walkie-talkie the male
d-class slowly got deeper into the
anomaly flight by flight predictably he
began to hear the intensely distressed
crying of a small child around 200
meters below him and immediately felt a
sense of paranoia and Dread wash over
his mind despite this Dr erdio ordered
him to keep going descending deeper and
deeper into the bowels of
scp-087 over time the sheer
psychological exhaustion of scp-087 was
beginning to take its toll on the
d-class leading him to taking a brief
break in order to nap however he awoke
with a violent start seeing the horrific
face of scp-087-1 staring down at him it
felt like all his worst nightmares had
come to life in order to escape the
monster he began to flee further down
into
scp-087 much like d-9884 before him it
would be the last mistake he ever made
when he finally reached the very bottom
of the 087 staircases the d-class
realized he was trapped Nowhere to Run
nowhere to hide suddenly the face of SCP
087-1 was hovering over him boring its
gaze into him as the d-class directed
his powerful flashlight at the creature
he saw that this time it was more than
just a face The Entity had a whole body
seven or eight feet long with that same
ghostly white and death-like appearance
it reached out with huge clawed hands
and grasped the d-class before the audio
and video feed cut out entirely the last
thing the attending researchers heard
was the screaming from the hapless
d-class and the crunch of his bones
within the creature's huge hands but of
course that's just one of three possible
insane discoveries at the very bottom of
scp-087 let's turn our attention to the
next one and see if its answer to the
scp-087 riddle seems to satisfy all of
our burning questions much like the
previous iteration a single male d-class
was sent into the clutches of scp-087 in
hopes of getting some answers on What
happened to Dean
9884 of course he was given all the
standard equipment from a 75 watt
flashlight to a defensive weapon to a
healthy supply of water and nutrition
bars none of which would save him in the
end like all the others this d-cost
descended down those accursed stairs
getting deeper and deeper when he
reached a certain point on the way down
he heard something but not the crying of
a child like all the others had reported
it was an adult woman's scream
specifically it was the scream of
d-9884 exactly as the foundation
researchers had herded over the audio
feed in her last moments before
disappearing this was progress the
researchers instructed this male d-class
to go deeper passing flight after flight
until finally the
scp-087-1 face appeared but again
something was different something was
wrong now it looked more like the face
of d988 4 just without her mouth and
pupils at scp-087-1 been stealing the
faces of its prior victims had the
previous face been stolen from a student
who'd gone missing from the campus these
were all questions the male d-class
didn't have time to ponder as he was too
busy running for dear life but he didn't
get far despite having no history of
such medical problems the male d-class
suddenly experienced a seizure while
attempting to escape and collapsed the
last thing his video feed picked up
before losing transmission was a pair of
long white arms emerging from the dark
crushing him inside of its huge hands
before dragging his unfolded corpse into
the darkness that's another chilling
potential account of the possible fourth
Expedition into
scp-087 but we can't stop now we still
have one more Tale of Terror to share
before this video is done in the next
and final iteration two d-classes one
male and one female were sent down
together in hopes of discovering what
had happened to D 9884 and by the end
they would have their answer but they
certainly wouldn't like it as the two of
them descended they saw the marks on the
wall where the adhesive lights from
Expedition 2 had been somehow torn off
but the deeper they descended the more
disturbing the things they found became
they discovered words clawed into the
stone walls each one revealing a piece
of a more frightening puzzle the deeper
down
scp-087 they traversed they descended
further sustaining minor injuries from a
foul-smelling encaustic substance left
on some of the walls and Floors around
them at some point along the journey a
light was dropped and in the brief
seconds of Darkness the female d-class
disappeared the male d-class was ordered
to go deeper and deeper into the
staircase until he finally began to hear
the crying of a little girl when he
reached the
666th floor he found found a wooden door
with the word home scratched into it he
steeled himself and entered the room but
it wasn't a room at all it was a field
shrouded in darkness with a distant tree
a little girl the one who had been
crying was finally actually here she
told the d-class that she'd always been
here and that her father had been trying
to find her a body so she could go
upstairs but for that to happen she'd
have to be properly birthed first that's
when the male d-class noticed the two
huge stone slabs just beyond the
darkness on one was the corpse of d9884
hanged by her wrists with thick metal
chains her abdomen had been fully cut
open as though a brutal c-section had
been performed on her and on the other
Stone was the female d-class who'd been
accompanying him this whole time strung
up but still very much alive seemingly
the next potential vessel for the little
girl's rebirth but the this didn't mean
that the male d-class would be left out
of the fun either after all the little
girl's father would need a new body too
if he wanted to accompany his daughter
upstairs the father in question being
scp-087-1 which appeared in the room
moments later and swooped in towards the
male d-class What followed was a battery
of nightmarish sounds as the darkness
expanded and consumed the field once
more not long after this the foundation
sealed off the entrance to scp-087
forever now knowing that it potentially
contained multiple hostile entities
intent on escaping into our world and
causing further damage students in the
area reported a number of frantic knocks
coming from the door for a brief period
after that until the foundation finally
had it properly soundproofed and the
issues were seemingly over with for now
so there you have it three potential
terrifying Secrets at the bottom of
scp-087 which do you think is the most
likely let us know down in the comments
after all when it comes to scp-087 it
seems you can always delve just a little
bit deeper welcome back comrade the case
of
scp-2273 also known as major Alexi
bellatrov has sparked your imagination
and you need to know more but even if
you're not familiar with the major his
story all you need to know is that it's
one of War tragedy and Alternate
Dimensions he first appeared in the town
of Danner Wisconsin on the 13th of
October 1989 during an unprecedented
seismic event when he was first
discovered the foundation researchers
assumed that he was an extraterrestrial
being on account of his Advanced organic
exoskeleton in a surprising move for
such an imposing creature bellatrov gave
himself up to Foundation agents without
a fight major belatrol was then
impounded in Foundation containment site
17 where he was interrogated thoroughly
over a series of interviews the
foundation ascertained that bellatrov
came from an alternate timeline where
Russia and the U.S are locked in a
so-called war to end the world thanks to
Advanced military technology given to
them by
scp-1000 bellatrov had nearly escaped
execution at the hands of American
soldiers and appeared in our timeline
now he is a prisoner of the advanced
suit that formerly kept him alive but
his story isn't over The Last Remnant of
a cold war turned hod has plenty left to
teach us something that you need to
understand about the SCP Foundation
before we go any further is that it
doesn't only exist in every nation
across the globe it also exists in every
Splinter reality across the Multiverse
and these Splinter realities offer a
countless multitude of tales of
different places different people and
different times today's tale concerns
major belatrav's future in a universe
where the secrecy of the foundation is
broken and the anomalous world needs to
find a way to fit in with our own the
year was 2018 like many humanoid
anomalies that the foundation was
holding in this timeline bellatrov was
released from containment he was no
longer an SCP he was now a mere Person
of Interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean bellatrol
was about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
Refugee from a broken alternate World
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the Mana charitable
Foundation this anomalous charity has
been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to Major bellatrov thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project Mana was
able to transport bellatrov back to his
home of volugrad in Russia there he
became something of a national celebrity
making headlines across the country
sitting down for interviews on every
Russian talk show and even being off
offered book deals but as a former
military man bellatrov was eager to
return to government life and run for a
government position however this
ambition didn't go very far bellatrov
was rejected by all the government
bodies he applied to even Vladimir Putin
wasn't eccentric enough to want an
insectosoid cyborg from another
dimension in his cabinet belatrov
endured a rough two years in volgraph he
was treated more like a sideshow freak
than a human being people didn't want to
rent apartments to him and he was never
able to find permanent employment even
entry-level jobs rejected him nobody
wanted to get food served to them by
what looked to be a seven-foot monster
and he seemed equally ill-suited to help
Russian women find the right perfume in
department stores in April of 2020
bellatrov had finally had enough he
contacted the Mana charitable Foundation
once again and asked to be relocated
they told him that some religious
institutions in the area including the
east Clockwork Orthodox Church we're
accepting and housing anomalous refugees
not long after this velotrov truly fell
off of the SCP foundation's radar but
one former Foundation operative was well
aware of major bellatrov's fate it's
2021 Dr Friedrich the site-17 anomaly
psychologist who'd conducted all the
initial interviews with bellatrov all
the way back in 1989 started receiving
letters from him there was no indication
as to his true location and they
appeared to have been handled by a Mana
charitable Foundation mail carrier in
Russia but Dr Friedrich was happy to
hear from an old friend nonetheless due
to a career of working near highly
radioactive anomalies like balotrov Dr
Friedrich was suffering from terminal
lymphoma it seemed almost like an act of
Divine Providence that bellatrov's
letters would come to him so close to
the end the two began a correspondence
and it was only after Dr friedrich's
eventual death that the letters came to
the SCP foundation's attention it was
from this final correspondence that the
foundation was able to answer the big
question whatever happened to Major
Alexi bellatrov in his first letter to
Dr Friedrich belatroff thanked him
profusely he knew that Dr Friedrich had
been a crucial part of him gaining
freedom from the foundation and credited
the therapeutic techniques taught to him
by Dr Friedrich with keeping him alive
and sane to this day bellatrov expressed
a mix of Amazement at this Brave New
World and a sense of profound weariness
as a man eternally locked into a weapon
of War he felt unsuited to a world in
peacetime he almost missed the scorched
irradiated Russia of his home Dimension
but most of all he missed site 17. he
missed Dr Friedrich he missed some of
his fellow anomalies like scp-507 the
teleporting man and scp-163 the
spacecraft he even missed the Simplicity
of being contained he hoped that Dr
Friedrich would right back in his second
letter bellatrov began detailing his
experience with the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church despite growing up in a
highly atheistic communist environment
bellatrov became enamored with the ways
of the church he found them to be highly
accepting of him in spite of his
unfortunate circumstances they displayed
a freedom in their faith that bellatrov
had never encountered before and he was
eager to be a part of it with the help
of Dr Friedrich belotrov was also
sending letters to some of his fellow
freed anomalies he's signed off by
saying that he had even started praying
something he'd never considered before
the next letter sent in 2027 struck a
much more somber tone it was sent
shortly after bellatrov discovered Dr
friedrich's diagnosis he wanted to
return and see the doctor one more time
but the Mana charitable Foundation
wouldn't allow him to return to site 17
believing he had been abused during his
time there belladrov gave Frederick his
prayers and well wishes and asked for a
number through which he could contact
his ailing old friend by the time the
next letter arrived in 2034 bellatrov
had become a fully fledged member of the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church he
referred to the other Monks at the
monastery as his brothers and sisters he
seemed to have finally found a true home
there and the others fondly referred to
him by the nickname Father anphil but
the True Heart of the letter is
bellatrov's deep concern for Dr
friedrich's Health notably in this
letter he often refers to Dr Friedrich
by his first name Thomas as though to
emphasize the urgency of the message
after the deaths of several of the
anomalies that bellatrov considered
friends he stated that he couldn't
handle losing anyone else his letter
ends with a poignant passage you may be
unmarried Dr Friedrich but you are not
on love you have to be strong for me you
have to be strong for yourself if you're
ever worried that you cannot find the
strength to continue think of the garden
you'll plant this spring I'd like to
share gardening photos with you again
not many of my brothers and sisters here
appreciate the simple beauty of a flower
bed or the effort that goes into growing
a patch of vegetables it's a beauty I'd
like to continue to share trust in the
power of Our Lord Thomas and thrust in
the power of modern medicine God is
smiling on you please be strong with
love and prayers Alexi belletrov this
letter arrived on the 15th of February
2034. sadly Dr Friedrich had already
passed away four days earlier we never
got to see Alexi's final letter and it
truly was his final letter with nobody
left for him in the world major
bellatrov stopped sending any
correspondence what we know about the
final years of belatron's life all comes
from a few scattered journal entries
translated from Russian after his
passing they provide clues as to the
kind of life he lived during the 29
years the foundation could not account
for his whereabouts and his actions the
first entry written on January 7 2035
paints a grim picture of bellatrobe
feeling broken and isolated in the
monastery he wrote today is the day that
our Monastery celebrates the birth of
our Lord however I feel no desire to
celebrate all of my friends in this
world are dead my brothers and sisters
are partaking in some celebration
outside my dormitory all of the required
ceremonies are complete neither they nor
whatever is happening out there will
lighten my mood velotrov also wrote
about losing the Comfort he once had in
his faith and his doubts about whether
he would be able to recapture that
Comfort but he had survived greater
traumas than this and he would continue
to press on as the months turned to
years and the years turned to decades
velotrov climbed through the ranks of
the monastery seeing as the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church practically
worshiped the concepts of
industrialization and mechanization the
fact that belletrov was permanently
encased in a biomechanical exoskeleton
probably made him seem even more Pious
to his holy brethren the final piece of
evidence collected by the foundation
Into The Life and Times of Alexi
bellatrov came just over 20 years later
in a final address written to comfort
his followers in preparation for his own
death bellatrov recounted the details of
his own life being born into a world of
fire death and mushroom clouds then his
life being suddenly saved by forces
Beyond his control only to place him
into containment for almost 30 years it
was only after accepting the teachings
of the church and accepting the
Clockwork Goddess that he felt he was
truly free from his past in this final
note bellatrov lay out some of the
teachings of his new religion the belief
in a great mechanized goddess who
planned all of reality according to
balatrov everything in her design fits
together perfectly like cogs in a
machine turning and twisting in unison
to create an ideal world he hoped to be
forgiven for the many violent sins he
committed in this military life and that
his contributions to this new world were
valuable at the very end of his address
bellatrov wrote I do not believe that my
time in this world is much longer
brothers and sisters when my time of
judgment comes do not mourn me I would
rather you remember these words the
goddess is most pleased with those who
see kind non-violent resolution to their
problems because a machine whose gears
grind against each other is a machine
that cannot work see truth but also
compassion the words are only words seek
out truth within them God bless you all
father Anvil a month after authoring
this statement records indicate that
Alexi belatrav was found dead in his
room having passed away peacefully in
his sleep from natural causes he lived A
Warrior's life but died a humble
priest's death the true tragedy in The
Strange Life of major Lexi bellatrov is
how little Choice he had in his
circumstances but thanks to this tale we
know he did what he could with the life
he was given his remains lay within the
graveyard at the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodoxy Monastery where he spent the
last years of his life with a life as
difficult as his own we can only imagine
he's glad to finally rest if you've been
a close follower of this channel for a
while now or even of the SCP Foundation
archive as a whole then there's a pretty
high chance that you might have heard of
scp-096 even if this just so happens to
be the First of rscp videos that you've
ever clicked on you still might have
seen the shy guy itself in various other
corners of the internet since the
earliest days of the SCP Foundation
scp-096 has gradually become one of the
most iconic and recognizable creatures
in the foundation's entire menagerie of
anomalous beings despite standing taller
than any ordinary person you might be
forgiven for mistaking SC cp096 for a
human being if you were to see it at a
distance but the creature is unusually
proportioned to say the least still
appearing Almost Human in its shape but
possessing long dangling arms that
almost reach the ground
scp-096's body is thin and hairless with
opaque clear white pupilous eyes and a
wide gaping mouth or so we've heard
thanks to drawings provided by someone
who sadly isn't with us anymore but you
might be surprised to learn that scp-096
doesn't really do all that much mostly
the tall spindly humanoid spends its
days walking mindlessly pacing around in
its containment cell sounds like most
days in a college dorm during lockdown
right that is of course until someone
dares to look at
scp-096's face it doesn't have to be
directly either it can be something as
simple as glancing at a photo or
watching a video of the creature but the
moment it is seen the exact second it is
perceived the wiring monster sure will
know having its face viewed in any way
will cause the shy guy to really live up
to its nickname the creature suffers
some sort of psychological meltdown
covering its face with its huge
claw-like hands and weeping
scp-096 quickly becomes utterly
inconsolable suffering from extreme
emotional distress until it simply can't
take it anymore pulling itself up to its
full looming height
scp-096 will stand and travel at
impossible speeds towards the person
that dared look at its face there's no
way to hide from the shy guy nothing can
stand in its path as it tracks down this
unlucky person and when it finds them
well it's certainly not pleasant somehow
without leaving any trace on their body
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it possibly even eating them
afterwards then it calms itself down
returns to its more docile State and is
typically bagged and brought back home
by whatever mobile task force is closest
scps 196 has killed many of the teams
sent to contain it proving itself to be
resistant to gunfire and any forms of
conventional Weaponry as much as being
only a tiny Speck in a photograph that
is enough to trigger the creature's
Relentless defense mechanism nobody can
get away from it either there is
literally nowhere in the entire world
that someone can run to escape
scp-096 not even crossing the oceans or
jumping aboard a plane is enough to stop
it and if our community questions video
on the matter is anything to go by you
may not even be safe in outer space the
SCP foundation's only real way to keep
the creature safely under wraps and
contained is to lock it up and force all
members of personnel to never ever look
at it while they hunt down any pieces of
recorded media still out there waiting
like a ticking Time Bomb so if no member
of the foundation can look at scp-096
how do they interact with it well
luckily there's a tale that answers
exactly fat known as a lesson in power
Dr Danielle Kowalski a member of the
foundation's research team assigned to
scp-096 was sent into the creature's
cell wearing a sleep mask you know the
kind you get on expensive flights what
she was really wishing for though was a
gas mask to go with it nobody had warned
her how bad scp-096 smelled then again
few had been as close to the creature as
she had and lived to tell the tale as a
child Danielle Kowalski had a fear of
stepping into the ocean her mother used
to warn her about treading on a stingray
and dying as a result giving her a
phobia that stayed with her for many
years but Danielle's father had
encouraged her to face her fear to
shuffle her feet on the ocean floor
kicking Up Sand so that the stingray
would know she was coming and would
simply just swim away perhaps if he
could have seen what kind of
Danielle was working with at the
foundation her father wouldn't have
tried to make her so Fearless maybe
there are some things that it's long
logical to be afraid of entering
scp-096's cell Dr Kowalski could hear
the monster's heaving breaths the
perfect mix between a frightened whimper
and a death rattle The Haunting sound of
a person's final gasp of air in the back
of her mind Danielle hopes she didn't
touch the creature by accident the
closer she got the tension and the heat
of its warm breath against her skin was
making the approach all the more
terrifying she had been issued with an
instant camera and took a photo in the
dark click the flash fired but with her
eyes covered she couldn't tell that was
good though that was the point if
Danielle could see the flash going off
she could see what else was in the room
and that would put her in even more
danger she was locked in with the kind
of stingray that wouldn't swim away even
if it knew she was there slowly Dr
Kowalski began blindly photographing the
cell around her stuffing each freshly
printed photo into her pocket as the
cameras spat them out over the span of
40 35 minutes she took a series of
pictures of the entire cell until the
film in the instant camera had run out
Danielle knew that she would probably
only need one picture but better to have
more just in case luckily none of her
foundation colleagues were around to
tell her how insane what she was doing
actually was they were all preoccupied
preparing the site for its first
official visit from the FBI this all
took place after what was known as the
broken masquerade had taken place
essentially knowledge of the SCP
Foundation and its Research into the
endless stream of anomalies it had
contained was all made public people
knew the truth now and the foundation
found itself in the one place it never
wanted to be the public I the
organization and its activities were
under the scrutiny of every journalist
on the planet and wants more information
about the scps and the anomalous world
of the foundation became known the world
would surely change forever Danielle
Kowalski knew all of this and told
herself that everyone would need
something for protection now she only
hoped her photographs would be enough 15
months later Dr Kowalski was
interrogated in her apartment by one
agent O'Brien he and a group of fellow
agents had barged into Danielle's home
demanding to know the location where a
number of scp-610 specimens were being
held scp-610 being of course the
infamous infection known as the flesh
that hates a disease capable of turning
human beings into a horrible deformed
monstrosities of Flesh agent O'Brien and
presumably whoever he was working for
was intent on turning these creatures
into weapons and the man had little
patience for a former Foundation
researcher who wasn't giving up the
answers that he wanted Danielle tried to
argue with the agent citing the Berlin
Accords against weaponized anomalies a
motion proposed to the United States
Senate that would forbid the use of
anomalous objects entities and creatures
as weapons for any country O'Brien was
an interest tested he claimed that if
the Kremlin in Russia had no intention
of ratifying such a law then America
wouldn't either the agent had his men
grab Danielle by her arm while he
grabbed her right middle finger and
began to push a thin knife under her
fingernail the former member of the
foundation tried to stifle her screen
but couldn't stop herself as the pain
struck as agent O'Brien tortured
Danielle he told her that the Russians
had all the information they would need
about scp-610 in order to turn the flesh
into some kind of weapon as far as he
was concerned the United States
government needed access to those
scp-610 specimens to know exactly what
they would be up against in the likely
event that Russia used the flesh that
hates against them and only a researcher
for the SCP Foundation the former senior
researcher on the scp-610 project would
know where to find those specimens you
don't think it reasonable for the United
States government to want to understand
what could be used against us O'Brien
asked does Danielle's blood trickled out
of her finger into his leather gloves
hell I don't care what you think we're
gonna do with it I want those specimens
when the agent finally let her go Dr
Kowalski tried to catch her breath
forcing herself not to scream in pain
again she pointed with her other
unharmed hand to her bedroom telling
O'Brien to check the bottom left drawer
she had placed a manila envelope in
there containing the only thing Danielle
had kept since departing the SCP
Foundation under O'Brien's orders his
man ransacked the nearby room and were
quickly able to find what they were
looking for the envelope was presented
to agent O'Brien who was no doubt
expecting to find a file inside
something that detailed the exact
location of those specimens he was
looking for so you can probably imagine
the dissatisfied look on his face when
he opened the envelope to find
photographs a collection of instant
photos all taken in a dark cell with all
of them depicting a tall thin humanoid
creature a being with long dangling arms
that almost reached the ground a thin
hairless body opaque pupilous eyes and a
wide gaping mouth Furious to once again
be denied the information he was looking
for O'Brien disregarded the pictures and
burned Dr Kowalski's neck with his
cigarette and his anger he said I think
your foundation sure thought they were
powerful hiding in the shadows but I'd
like to explain to you why you're wrong
the agent then went on to describe his
time as a member of the DEA in the late
1980s and how he'd been involved in the
hunting of notorious cartel boss Pablo
Escobar I had a narco in custody every
bit as uncooperative as you are now the
man had insisted that Escobar owned all
the Colombian law enforcement but a
younger O'Brien had argued that if that
was the case and they possessed all this
power then why did Pablo Escobar's men
hide their guns why smuggle drugs in
secret and bury their money where no one
would find it if they really had the
control they claimed much like Escobar
bars cartel the SCP Foundation had
always moved in the shadows a power that
O'Brien believed to have really belonged
to the government your anomalies belong
to us your research belongs to us your
life belongs to us he told Dr Kowalski
suddenly one of the other agents noticed
movement outside of the apartment the
second that Danielle saw a long arm
phase through a wall with gray skin like
that of a corpse she snapped her eyes
shut O'Brien and his men Drew all their
guns and opened fire on the monster that
had walked through the wall as if it
wasn't even there all the while Danielle
Kowalski kept her eyes shut the sounds
of screaming and snapping bones and a
sickening slurping noise filled the air
but she made sure not to look within a
few quick moments of panic and agonizing
pain it was over the apartment was quiet
apart from strange breathing like a mix
of a frightening whimper and a death
rattle run along now zero nine six Dr
Kowalski told the shy guy there are
worse monsters in this world than you
some anomalies kill for fun others for
food others because they simply have no
choice on the other side of the coin
somewhat nothing more than to spread
love joy and happiness but it's rare
that you see an anomaly that has
genuinely pure intentions but his
attempts to do good often turn deadly
one such figure and the subject of
today's tale is
scp-049 the plague doctor if you're at
all familiar with the SCP Foundation
then you will have likely heard of the
infamous plague doctor for those of you
who haven't here's a bit of context for
scp-049 he appears exactly as you'd
expect a plague doctor from the late
medieval period or Renaissance periods a
tall figure shrouded in Long Black robes
a hood over his head with only a
Venetian beaked mask protruding from
underneath these aren't just a fashion
statement I've either the SCP Foundation
discovered that these are all part of
scp-049's physical body sharing a
similar structure to muscle and bone the
plague doctor's primary goal is to find
those he considers to be infected with
something he refers to as the pestilence
if he ever senses this Affliction he
will attempt to make direct skin contact
with the person carrying it why because
scp-049's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's all the plague doctor does
goes from person to person killing them
with his deadly touch but you would be
wrong once he's killed the victim
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery on their corpse
using equipment he produces from his
mysterious and apparently bottomless
magical medical Satchel he injects a
number of unknown chemicals into the
corpse which brings them back to life
and turns them into an instance of
scp-049-2 or or in other words a vicious
mindless zombie at present scp-049 is
kept secure in a holding cell by the
foundation under watch by surveillance
cameras for 24 hours a day and that is
where our Story begins the tale of a
deadly dangerous doctor and his days
spent in captivity locked away in a cage
contained by the SCP Foundation there he
sits alone it is a tale known only by
the simple title going home it begins
with the plague doctor left alone in his
cell he had been there for such a long
time that he'd forgotten exactly how
long but there he sat taunted by the
sensation of pestilence around him it
was a small almost undetectable feeling
but it reeked of Decay and disease
hanging in the very air particles of
scp-049 cell although they have long
since stopped the practice the SCP
Foundation used to send its doctors and
researchers into 0 four nines is Sal
bringing him cadavers as test subjects
the plague doctor would use these
specimens to hone his craft perfecting
his method of transforming the dead into
instances of
scp-049-2 but of course the doctors
working for the foundation weren't
exactly free of disease themselves and
they too often needed to be cured by his
touch and soon they stopped visiting
scp-049 in person leaving him alone in
his cell even these so-called people of
science feared the true cure it seemed
they would talk to the plague doctor via
an intercom system interviewing him and
asking questions about what he did or
how he felt one question stood out to
scp-049 the foundation researchers have
asked him if he had any regrets for what
he had done to people the plague doctor
thought it foolish to even ask and then
even the questions coming through the
intercom stopped after a while for a
time as cp049 was happy in his cell left
alone with his thought thoughts say from
the diseases of the outside world the
black doctor was at peace for a change
resting in Comfort until the familiar
smell of pestilence returned the
presence of disease drove him to attempt
an escape producing his medical
implements from his bag he kept
concealed in his robes
scp-049 tried to pry open the door to
his cell he wasn't sure how long it took
the passage of time had long since
stopped registering to him but
eventually he had it open just enough so
that he could pass through out into the
corridor beyond the chamber that he had
been held in there was no one else
around no doctors or researchers or
Foundation security Personnel no one to
stop the plague doctor from following
the stench of the disease that had
driven him to find a way out of
containment navigating through the
hallways of the foundation facility
scp-049 tracked the source of the
disease to a locker with little trouble
he opened it finding a metallic box
within as he studied the container his
fingers found the button that opened it
it hissed as the gases kept the inside
of the Box mixed with the air the cold
Vapor hit the plague doctor in the face
catching him by surprise and making him
drop the Box reasserting himself the
blade doctor bent over and picked up the
contents of the refrigerated container a
single mosquito it wasn't the insect
itself that had drawn scp-049 out of his
cell true mosquitoes are known to spread
diseases like malaria but it was what
was inside this mosquito that the doctor
wanted to eradicate its blood sack was
full swollen with dark fluid that
scp-049 knew to be infected using the
metal box as an improvised operating
table he produced his bag of medical
implements and the doctor began to
operate he retrieved a syringe from his
bag and a vial filled with thick black
liquid half filling the syringe with the
liquid he plunged the needle into the
mosquito and extracted the blood that
the insect was carrying the infected
bodily fluid mixed with the medicine in
the doctor's syringe leaving the bug is
little more than a dry husk the plague
doctor watch does the two substances
mixed together before stabbing back into
the mosquito filling the creature with a
combination of both liquids he refused
to leave any trace of pestilence in the
insect's body the mosquito twitched
itself back to life looking around until
it saw scp-049 observing it who's there
it asked where's merley there is no one
here but me and you the doctor explained
you are in a prison though the wardens
eat scenes have lived a prison the
insect responded oh God I'm at site 19.
naturally it seemed rather strange for a
mosquito to be able to talk let alone
know about the highly classified site-19
but as is always the case in the SCP
Foundation the strange always has an
anomalous explanation you see this
mosquito was not like any other for one
she even had a name it was Leslie as it
turned out Leslie was part of an SCP one
of the foundation's own creation
scp-3774 these were genetically and
cybernetically enhanced species of
mosquito why would the foundation spend
time and resources creating something
like this originally they were designed
as an undetectable covert way of keeping
tabs on Persons of Interest to the SCP
Foundation the plague doctor thought it
odd that after having spent so much time
in prison there that he should finally
learn the name of site 19 from a
mosquito of all things Leslie seemed to
be in a state of panic however urgently
insisting that she had to get back to
someone named Merle as cp049 had no clue
what she meant he'd never encountered
anyone that went by that name and had no
idea where to even begin looking I know
where he lives I can find it the
mosquito insisted I just I don't know
how I could ever get out of here she was
wary of the creature she found her self
talking to despite being a genetically
engineered insect Leslie was for all
intents and purposes an agent of the SCP
Foundation and now she was currently
conversing with an anomaly that she knew
nothing about but he wasn't trying to
harm her in fact whatever the plague
doctor had done seemed to have revived
her I have gotten myself this far and
now that I have I have no further reason
to stay here the doctor announced
holding a handout for Leslie to fly up
to then then you'll help me get out of
here she asked readying her wings and
landing in his palm I will
scp-049 agreed the pair introduced
themselves properly Leslie giving
scp-049 her name while he just
instructed her to call him doctor before
they set out together after almost a
week of traveling on foot through rugged
terrain and harsh winds the plague
doctor and his insect companion had yet
to encounter another living Soul thick
dark clouds hung in the sky above them
and Leslie soon found found it hard to
remember what the sun looked like she
feared that she might even forget
merly's face we're close she said just a
few more miles and then and then we will
arrive
scp-049 finished her sentence tell me
doctor why did you come all this way
with me Leslie the mosquito asked you
could have left when we got out gone on
your own way in response he gave one
simple sentence merely because I wanted
to finally the Intrepid pair arrived at
a house once belonging to Merle it was
abandoned ramshackle in a total state of
disrepair decades had passed since
anyone had set foot in the place the
living room that had once been so
familiar to Leslie had now been
transformed into a Barren empty space
the side of it made her so distraught
with sadness that she would have been
sick if mosquitoes could be sick Merle
whoever he was or had been was now
nowhere to be found one of Leslie's
cybernetic enhancements was an internal
positioning system giving her all sorts
of data and readouts including a clock
it told her just how long she'd been
away for I've been dead for 200 years
the mosquito cried in the palm of the
doctor's hand then the Merle is is dead
everyone everyone is dead she kept
repeating it to herself over and over as
if she was trying to convince herself of
what had happened eventually the words
lost all meaning as he held Leslie in
his hands perhaps the plague doctor felt
sorry for the mosquito after all the
plague doctor had always had a
respectful polite personality despite
his frightening exterior he had always
believed that he'd acted in service of
the greater good trying to cure the
world of pestilence to bring the end of
disease he only ever killed because to
him it was in his victims best interest
for him to perform his procedures to his
captors at the SCP Foundation the doctor
had been courteous and cooperative and
he acted the same towards his fellow
scps not just less but even the sort of
anomalies with nothing but hatred in
their hearts the doctor saw them as just
further victims of the pestilence in
need of curing
scp-049 sat in silence for a while with
his mosquito friend letting her mourn
the loss of Merle and everything she had
ever known where will you go now he
asked still in tears barely able to
speak through her sobs Leslie decided
that she wanted to stay where she was
the insect wanted to live where Merle
had lived in a desperate attempt to
recapture the world that she once knew
sitting in the plague doctor's gloved
hands still sobbing even though she had
run out of Tears Leslie said any minute
any minute Merle will come through the
door the plague doctor held his tiny
companion where she was while she
grieved then I would wait for him he
told her here with you it rides against
the snow red raw and vicious too many
mouths too many limbs twitching and
dripping once it looked a lot like you
but now it's something different
entirely if ever it escapes its bounds
it'll rebuild the whole world and its
image it is known and feared by everyone
with sufficient clearance at the SCP
Foundation and for good reason it'll
infect anyone and anything and a death
sentence is preferable to infection it
is a disease that thinks the crawling
corruption the flesh that hates or if
you fear its true name too much to speak
it and find comfort in the
categorization and clinical eyes of the
SCP Foundation
scp-610
scp-610 is a contagious skin disease
transmitted by direct contact anyone
infected with It suffers a horrific
mutation turning them into fleshy
inhuman monstrosities these infected
creatures will attack and affect anyone
nearby that isn't also carrying
scp-610 this also happens to be the
flesh described and adored by those
following the Twisted religion of
sarcasism a violent cult and group of
interests that worships flesh corruption
and disease and as the foundation
operatives tasked with observing groups
of interests know sarcasism is a sect
that directly opposes the machine
revering Church of the broken God and to
understand the events of the tale known
to the SCP Foundation as aftermath the
beginning that leads to its brutal and
world-changing end one must first
understand the endless conflict between
these two groups the Church of the
broken God is a religion that the SCP
Foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
biological flesh-based life is an
inherently wrong and evil Abomination
they worship mechanization the process
of making organic bodies something more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church two gods yaldaboff
and meccane created Humanity together
yaldaboth was the god of Flesh and
animal Instinct granting humans bodies
meanwhile the god of machine and
intellect McCain blessed man with the
power of free thought has humankind
developed machines yaldaboth became
enraged that they were ignorant of the
instincts she had given them and
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man as the church's Legend goes McCain
acted as Humanity's Savior and tried
desperately to stop yaldabov the god of
machines shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow God fragments of
McCain rained down on planet Earth now
the Church of the broken God believes it
is their duty to recover these missing
parts there could potentially be
hundreds of pieces knee needed to
rebuild McCain and a number of these
happen to be cataloged scps that the
foundation is either aware of or has in
containment Our Story begins not with
the long-awaited return of McCain the
broken God instead it begins with a man
a foundation foot soldier named Roderick
Freeman this is the story of aftermath
in 2003 at the age of 17 roderick's
ambition was to join the U.S Navy and
become a member of the renowned Navy
Seals after enlisting and completing
three years of rigorous training he
achieved his ambition only to climb even
further to Heights he never could have
foreseen in 2017 Roderick now as seal
was recruited by the SCP Foundation
after his skills and aptitude caught the
attention of their embedded recruiters
he joined one of the foundation's mtfs
or mobile task forces elite units that
are often sent in to directly deal with
anomalous threats specifically Freeman
became a member of MTF news 7. also
known by the code name hammer down the
task force you call in when literally
nothing else can do the job to bring
hammer down onto the scene for anything
less than a potential XK is like
swatting a housefly with a nuclear
warhead so Roderick a gun hoe soldier
boy if there ever was one would fit
right in but what does this mobile task
force have to do with all that talk
about the Church of the broken God and
the flesh that hates well after an
incident that broke out in the urkutsuka
area in Russia they were the ones
responsible for cleaning up the mess
Left Behind according to roderick's
account a robot the size of a small
building was spotted in this area during
December 2018. this 30-foot tall robot
had apparently come to wipe out a
rapidly spreading disease as you can
probably guess that disease was
scp-610 the flesh that hates at first
the global occult coalition had fired on
the robot launching a volley of
ballistic missiles in an attempt to take
it down this move failed the robot
protecting itself so that not even a
piece of shrapnel could hit it it barely
seemed phased by the attack and went
about destroying remnants of scp-610 as
it found them any infected with the
flesh were obliterated and when its job
was done the robot simply laughed
perhaps this wasn't quite the grandiose
return for meccane that the Church of
the broken God had envisioned for their
deity but it was nevertheless the
long-awaited return they got what had
happened was that the SCP Foundation
called a lifted Veil scenario the truth
was now out the world would soon be
aware of the existence of anomalies
afterwards Freeman and the rest of
hammerdown recovered a series of tablets
that had been left behind by McCain each
of them bore a simple repeated phrase in
a variety of language just the words I
will return a short time later riots
began to spark across the world it was a
disaster too big for even the foundation
to cover up according to Roderick
multiple anomalous groups such as the
Serpent's hand and the chaos Insurgency
had gone public in Mexico the Insurgency
became involved in illegal businesses
that gave the cartels an anomalous run
for their ill-gotten money while members
of the Serpent's hand used the air of
tension to incite riots in short
everything was a mess and this
eventually escalated to a full-scale
Civil War in Mexico in 2021 during the
build up to this around 2019 there was
unrest around the world and mobile task
forces like hammerdown were being
deployed to train alongside various
Public Safety organizations all in the
hopes of getting the world prepared for
the storm Gathering all around them the
Insurgency and the hand had revealed the
truth about anomalies to the world and
so the foundation's mtfs were aiding law
enforcement Special Forces and the like
readying them to defend against the
anomalous in 2022 the foundation finally
decided to intervene in the situation
down in Mexico where the chaos
Insurgency and the Serpent's hand had
been causing disruption Roderick Freeman
was one of those sent to Juarez coming
face to face with former cartel members
turned lackeys for the Insurgency the
chaos Insurgency had been fighting with
the foundation for decades and knew all
their tactics combine that with the
ferocity and brutality of a lifelong
cartel member and even the toughest
Soldier is in for a fight as it turns
out the fight wasn't even the worst part
for our dedicated Little Soldier while
attempting to transport a person of
interest across the Texas Mexico border
Roderick and his Squad were ambushed by
a sniper during the attack Freeman
received a wound to his spine that left
him paralyzed from the hip down however
even though the foundation didn't like
to admit it the Church of the broken God
was actually highly skilled in surgery
after all they worshiped mechanization
and would often augment themselves using
technology or to use roderick's own
words if you wanted an iPhone in your
skull in 2009 they could have pulled it
off if you wanted to be able to turn the
lights on and off in your home by
blinking they had an upgrade for that if
you lost the use of your legs because of
a sniper on a rooftop in Juarez they had
you covered thanks to members of the
church there had been a new
technological Revolution since the
lifting of the veil by 2024 devices that
felt like they were 20 years more
advanced than technology should have
been were now commonly available so
that's how Roderick Freeman was able to
walk again however the SCP Foundation
refused to let him return to duty
forcing him into an administrative role
frustrated he applied for a job as a
containment specialist meanwhile the
state of the world was constantly
changing with the SCP Foundation handing
over safe anomalies to World governments
new divisions and Department were being
formed to deal with the containment of
scps there was even an anomaly
registration program that allowed people
to call 9-1-1 to report dangerous or
life-threatening anomalies anyone
exhibiting anomalous abilities could Now
find doctors or therapists rather than
being carted off to a containment cell
in short the foundation's days were
numbered however this was not as idyllic
as it sounds according to Roderick this
should have been a chance for the civil
rights of anomalous people to be
respected something that the Serpent's
hand had been campaigning for since
their modern Inception instead it meant
that anyone with anomalous traits
perceived to be dangerous was arrested
as threats to National Security things
were nowhere near as restrictive as
under the foundation the safer anomalies
could even have visits from family but
there was one boy Thomas whom Rodrick
had to look after remarking that he
wasn't old enough to be kept in a
containment setting little did Roderick
know the tests that were being run on
Thomas we're keeping tabs on him somehow
the boy was able to use anomalous
abilities to watch where Roderick was at
all times the SCP Foundation was finally
disbanded in 2027 with the containment
of anomalies becoming the responsibility
of the global Coalition Council this
organization had long been the official
sanctioned counterpart to the more off
the books Foundation despite their more
violent methods but now the GOC was
making their work known to the public
but with the foundation gone Roderick
was out of work picking up odd jobs over
the next six years there was widespread
criticism of the SCP Foundation and its
dubious methods the dark things they'd
done to keep anomalies contained
civilians killed entire populations
given memory wiping drugs to forget
about scps the horrific treatment of
d-class personnel a document containing
details about these practices and more
was leaked causing an outcry the SCP pen
foundation's brutal methods were
declared to be crimes against humanity
alongside this paranoia about anomalies
was spreading governments were
encouraging their citizens to report
paranormal happenings and people with
anomalous traits were being registered
and arrested in roderick's account he
says when people don't understand
something one of two things will happen
they will try to understand it so they
can use it for their own ends or and
this is far more likely they will grow
afraid of it and try to destroy it so it
was when Humanity rediscovered anomalies
former Foundation employees were
declared Public Enemy Number One with
anomalous persons at close second when
former members of the foundation began
to find themselves on trial by the
United Nations the public began
executing any ex-foundation Personnel
they could find at first local police or
even the National Guard would intervene
but some eventually started actively
helping the Vigilante mobs there was
nowhere for Roderick to hide the FBI
even used the unusual incident unit to
track down the foundation's remaining
members some had even been hired by the
uiu to bring in their former co-workers
and for anyone who knows how utterly
useless the unusual incidence unit are
to be brought in for execution by them
is a truly humiliating death unsure who
to trust Roderick turned to agent
Leonard Wells a man whose life he had
once saved meeting at a diner in
Wisconsin Leonard agreed to smuggle
Roderick to Russia for five thousand
dollars getting him safely out of the
FBI's jurisdiction Freeman agreed and
was then led to an SUV with three other
men that he didn't recognize according
to Leonard they were just there to help
smuggle Roderick the five of them drove
to an isolated stretch of road only to
stop something was terribly wrong
Leonard told Roderick to exit the car
claiming that they would need to switch
vehicles as the SUV drove off Leonard
handed Roderick a flashlight and told
him to Signal a nearby Grove of trees
and then according to a report Roderick
X Freeman was wanted by the U.S
government for the actions he was
involved in during his time at the SCP
Foundation he was believed to have been
responsible for human rights violations
and was picked up by agents of the FBI's
unusual incidence unit the report
claimed that Roderick engaged the uiu
agents with a small firearm although he
had reached out to agent Leonard Wells
for help whether he was executed or
tried to run away Roderick Freeman was
shot and killed but that was far from
the worst part about his death dying is
bad enough but witnessing death
especially at a young age is something
that can have a long lasting effect but
who was there to see what happened or
rather who could see without being there
Thomas the young anomalous boy Roderick
had been assigned to had seen the whole
thing the world had changed undeniably
it has been said that the foundation
dies in the dark so that we can live in
the light but when this same light was
turned on the foundation itself it
seemed that they couldn't survive under
its scrutiny either whether the world is
better or worse without them is
something only you can decide now first
things first just in case you aren't yet
familiar with scp-049 otherwise known as
the infamous plague doctor then we're
here to bring you up to speed it'll help
you get the most out of today's tale
scp-049 is a tall humanoid entity always
seen wearing long black robes a hood
over its head and a beaked mask
protruding from underneath the same kind
of mask worn by physicians during the
height of the Black Death however these
parts of the plague doctor's attire
aren't just a costume the SCP Foundation
discovered that all of
scp-049's outfit is actually part of his
physical body in other words the robes
the hood The Mask they are all made out
of muscle and bone the plague doctor's
only real goal in mind is to hunt down
any person it deems to be infected The
Entity often refers to something he
calls the pestilence and upon sensing
this Affliction in a human being
scp-049 will attempt to make direct skin
contact with whoever is apparently
carrying said pestilence the plague
doctor's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's as bad as it gets that this
creature just goes from person to person
killing them via touch but you would be
wrong it gets worse killing one of his
victims is only the start afterwards
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery defiling and
repurposing the person's corpse using
equipment that he produces from his
iconic doctor's bag he injects a number
of unknown chemicals into a person's
carcass eventually turning them into an
instance of
scp-049-2 in essence a vicious
incredibly aggressive zombie the most
bizarre part in scp-049 is mine this
means he's just cured you naturally as
cp049 is already held in containment
safely Locked Away by the SCP Foundation
at present scp-049 resides in a humanoid
holding cell closely monitored by
surveillance cameras for 24 hours a day
every single day the SCP Foundation used
to send its doctors and researchers into
scp-049 cell or would make a habit of
bringing him cadavers as test subjects
fresh bodies for the plague doctor to
hone his surgical skills the researchers
would keenly observe the doctor
transforming the dead into instances of
scp-049-2 but these researchers and
doctors working for the foundation
weren't exactly free of disease meaning
every time they entered scp-049 cell
they were at risk of receiving his
deadly touch in this cage with this
deadly dangerous doctor that spends all
his time in captivity that's where our
story starts but while you might expect
a story about the plague doctor to
revolve solely around violence disease
and death this tale offers a surprising
Divergence boiled scrambled and fried is
a story about an unexpected New Life
coming into existence in a frankly
bizarre fashion all starting in that
tiny containment chamber where scp-049
had been held since the foundation first
captured him it had been increasingly
obvious to the researchers observing him
that something was quite wrong with a
plague doctor for the first time since
the doctor had arrived in the
foundation's custody he appeared to have
fallen ill unexpectedly the security
cameras that were trained on him day in
and day out recorded scp-049 groaning in
pain clutching his stomach as he limped
weakly around the confines of his cell
had the pestilence finally gotten the
better of the good doctor was he too now
infected the same as the world around
him the foundation's Medics were
confused baffled as to what could
possibly be wrong with the creature of
course it would also have been easier to
examine the doctor if they could easily
touch him without the risk of dying or
if his body wasn't made of skin robes
nonetheless the plague doctor was
brought to a medical station for a
proper diagnosis under the orders of one
Dr Richard omel a foundation Doctor Who
specialized in taking care of humanoid
anomalies and who had been assigned as
scp-049's caretaker the creature tried
to assure Dr omell that he was strong
enough to withstand the intense pain he
was obviously suffering from putting on
gloves for safety Dr olmel felt a
distinct lump with an scp-049 stomach
initially believing it to be a case of
abdominal distension this is a condition
that occurs when gases or fluids build
up in the stomach and cause it to swell
up and inflate usually as a symptom of
another internal disease but scp-049
reassured his caretaker that his
condition wasn't the result of any
disease and in fact it had even
apparently happened before Dr omell
asked scp-049 why he had never told the
foundation about this or why the
creature wouldn't explain what was
happening I did not think you would
believe me so I said nothing
scp-049 explained doctor I am pregnant
I'm sorry but I can't explain it please
just let me return to my cell I need to
make the proper preparations naturally
this statement was met with stunned
belief by Dr omell especially seeing as
the foundation had been observing
scp-049 through security cameras for
months on end without stopping the
creature couldn't explain tensing up and
breathing heavily due to suffering
obvious and intense pain as Dr omell
rushed out to grab more members of
medical staff the plague doctor
continued struggling against the aches
letting out his loudest of cries yet as
an extreme bout of Agony surged through
him a pearly white egg gently tumbled
out from scp-049's robes just as dark Dr
omell and a group of foundation Medics
arrived staring in shock at what had
just happened seeming to recover quite
quickly the plague doctor asked to be
Unshackled and returned to a cell to
tend to the egg worried it would die
unless he was able to care for it as the
Shock Doctor omel agreed as cp049 gently
picked up the egg and cradled it in his
arms of course this all came as quite an
unexpected turn of events to the
foundation reports were filed and
archive entries had to be updated but
they allowed the plague doctor to keep
his egg and raise it perhaps just so
they could watch and research as it
happened instead of out of any sense of
kindness for the next five days the
creature was fixated entirely on caring
for the egg all his energy focused on it
he built a nest in the corner of his
containment cell out of fabric and paper
and would sit on the egg in order to
keep it warm during that time a number
of foundation researchers assigned to
watch over scp-049 reported that they
had heard clucking noises coming through
the speakers in the observation room now
assigned to watch and report on
scp-049's progress Dr Romel watched the
plague doctor from the observation room
connected to the cameras and audio
recording devices in the creature's cell
ever since the bizarre and unanticipated
birth omel had been given the task of
compiling an extensive report on
everything that took place within the
cell for the most part everything seemed
fine or as fine as something so unusual
could seem the egg was in a healthy
condition nonetheless although the whole
event had the foundation doctor
wondering
scp-049 had always had a somewhat
bird-like appearance helped in no small
part by that Infamous beak-shaped mask
did the fact that this creature could
apparently lay eggs mean that the plague
doctor was some form of humanoid bird an
avian human hybrid that only mimicked
the plague doctors of old or had those
medieval Physicians created their masks
to emulate
scp-049 which had come first the plague
doctors or the plague doctor a debate as
confusing and cyclical as the one about
the chicken or the egg and now the
plague doctor also had an egg I don't
know about you but I'm starting to get a
headache just thinking about it
scp-049 had begun to softly Peck at the
surface of the egg when Dr omell decided
to step in and look for some answers to
his burning questions over the speakers
in 049 cell he asked for an explanation
the plague doctor answered that he was
checking his egg for signs of life
within its shell as if that answer
should have been obvious and he had
succeeded there was definitely something
living inside as the plague doctor
returned to sitting Atop The Egg omel
asked outright if scp-049 was in fact a
bird it was uncommon if not downright
unheard of for a humanoid anomaly to lay
eggs like this after a moment's thought
scp-049 replied with no as far as I'm
aware I have never been a bird yet that
producing eggs is natural to me he
explained that while this had happened
before it had been at least a few
decades since the last time then the
plague doctor went back to sitting on
his egg humming as it rocked back and
forth in the nest ten days passed after
the egg had first arrived and now
scp-049 cell was brimming with activity
Foundation Personnel had fitted the room
with a glass screen to protect them from
the plague doctor with researchers
piling in into the safe side carrying
cameras and hurriedly taking notes
protected by a number of guards the big
day had seemingly arrived whatever had
been brimming and Brewing inside the egg
was about to hatch as the researchers
all whispered to each other with
excitement and Intrigue
scp-049 stood protectively on the other
side of the room just waiting in
fascinated expectation the pearlescent
egg started to shake suddenly its pale
surface cracking the crack spread from
the center of the egg forking across the
shell like a lightning bolt over a dark
cloudy Sky something underneath was
pushing through pressing outwards from
within the egg splitting it apart as it
had tapped and pecked its way to Freedom
a small white beak poked a hole through
the shell that surrounded it piercing
the egg at last the creature within this
spawn of the plague doctor began to tear
itself through the barrier that had kept
it safe from the outside world until it
was ready to take its first steps with
both arms the thing tore itself out of
the egg all under the watch of the
foundation's doctors and researchers who
were stunned to see another plague
doctor emerging from the egg it was
small much smaller than the father that
had birthed it and cared for it while it
was waiting to hatch but it was
nonetheless a perfect miniature version
of scp-049 complete with the same kind
of robes the same beaked mask even with
a little hat on top of its head with a
gasp of pure excitement the original
plague doctor lifted up his new Mini
self and hugged the child than his arms
the excitement that had filled the room
up now quickly dissipated as the
audience of foundation Personnel quickly
realized that they had just witnessed
the live birth of a brand new anomaly of
which they understood virtually nothing
as Dr omell stepped forward to
cautiously ask scp-049 to put down its
Offspring the smaller plague doctor
smacked omel's hand with a stick before
leaping from its father's arms and
dashing out of the cell as alarms began
to blare indicating a breaching
containment
scp-049 wiped a tear from his eyes
stating he is the cure the new smaller
plague doctor now designated as
scp-049-j seems to have a talent for
evading capture by the foundation and
for frequently escaping containment
unlike its predecessor
scp-049 this Offspring has a body
beneath its robes that is composed
mostly of moss wads of tissue and
smaller plague doctor masks during the
occasions in which it has been
successfully detained by the foundation
scp-049-j has claimed that it is in fact
a powerful magical Doctrine wizard with
the ability to cure all that ails
mankind however to date it has been
unable to cure anything usually making
medical conditions actively worse my
headache included close your eyes and
pray for salvation we're returning to
the lanky lethal lad whose Rampage is
often result in legendary losses of life
it's scp-096 the shy guy longtime fans
of the channel will no doubt know this
anomalous monster like the back of their
hand after all we have several videos on
the subject that are definitely worth
checking out sometime but to get the
full benefit of today's tale we'll do a
quick refresh for any potential
newcomers in the audience good to have
you here let's start with the basics the
first thing you'll probably notice about
096 is its daunting size and rather
unusual bodily proportions while mostly
humanoid in shape the shy guy has long
dangling arms that almost reach the
ground its body is thin and hairless
with opaque clear white pupilous eyes
and a wide gaping mouth it is a truly
chilling sight to behold an Abomination
that conjures up nightmares just to look
at it and we mean that literally you
don't want to look at this thing and
we'll get to why in a moment
scp-096 doesn't really do much during an
average day usually This Tall spindly
humanoid entity will spend its down time
just aimlessly pacing around in its
containment cell and perhaps
occasionally taking a nap pretty
relatable right especially if you've
been trapped in your college dorm room
during the lockdown but if some unlucky
Soul should dare to look at
scp-096 specifically its horrible face
that's when the monster starts to act
very differently now someone doesn't
have to be directly looking at scp-096
to make this happen even glancing at a
blurry distorted photo of it or watching
security footage of the creature can
have the same deadly result you see the
moment scp-096 is faces seen the wiring
monster will know when this happens the
creature suffers what appears to be a
psychological meltdown covering its face
with its huge claw-like hands and
weeping hence the nickname Shy Guy
utterly inconsolable and suffering from
extreme emotional distress eventually
the creature will be unable to take it
anymore standing up scp-096 will then
travel towards whoever dared to look at
it using anomalous speed to hunt down
the person that saw its face the
foundation has proven that it is
unquestionably impossible for anyone to
hide from scp-096 literally nothing can
stand in its path as it tracks down its
victim not walls or locked doors even
being aboard a boat in the middle of the
ocean or in a plane in mid-air can
prevent it from finding you and when it
does find you it's not a pleasant sight
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it without leaving any detectable
trace on their body the monster is
impervious to gunfire in all other forms
of conventional Weaponry it can't be
killed or even so much as harmed even if
the shy guy is only seen as a tiny
little speck in a photograph this will
be enough to trigger the creature's
Relentless defense mechanism so because
of this the SCP foundation's only real
way to keep the creature safely locked
up is in an airtight steel cube with no
security cameras or surveillance tools
of any kind all members of personnel are
reminded that they are to never ever
look at it but what if they could what
if somehow someone was able to
neutralize
scp-096's anomalous abilities or was
resistant to being killed when the
creature inevitably tracked them down
this is how the tale known as picture
perfect begins what do you think boys is
she a beauty or what Dr clef proclaimed
to a group of his fellow high-ranking
Foundation researchers the group looked
in confusion and unease at what clef had
been referring to namely a photograph
that he just hung up on the wall of his
office a photo of what though well a
four foot by five foot picture of none
other than
scp-096 of course naturally the other
researchers shared a mixture of shock
and dismay at what clef had just done as
you would if one of your co-workers hung
up a photo of a creature that could kill
you just for looking at that said photo
we've lost a number of Staff members
from around the scp-explained office
that same way let's just say the
Christmas party last year was not that
fun Dr klaff had long been one of the
more enigmatic and mysterious scientists
working at the foundation with the
exception of the Elusive and Infamous o5
Council alto clef was formerly an
operative for the global occult
Coalition as well as being known to be a
bit of a gun enthusiast and all-around
crazy wild card Cliff earned his own
brand of infamy for his rumored practice
of brutally decommissioning dangerous
scps and you can probably guess what we
mean by that he's the foundation's go-to
Executioner and a specialist in dealing
with reality-bending anomalies would you
expect any less from an ex-goc joining
clef in his office where the likes of Dr
Jack Bright another Infamous Foundation
researcher Dr bright also known as
scp-963-2 was assigned to conduct
experiments on an anomalous amulet
scp-963 which resulted in his death at
the hands of scp-076 able however
anomalous properties of the amulet gave
bright the ability to inhabit new bodies
after his death specifically anyone who
also touches the amulet which kills the
host and allows bright to take control
of their body while technically Immortal
Dr bright isn't exactly stoked about
that fact often seeking out death and
wanting to know exactly what it feels
like also present at the unveiling of Dr
clough's photo of scp-096 was his
friendly rival Dr kundraki while usually
Gruff and anti-social kondraki is an
expert in perception-based anomalies
normally called upon by the foundation
to photograph scps that would otherwise
be invisible or imperceivable Dr
Sumerian a member of the foundation's
Ethics Committee was also in the room as
Dr cleff proudly showed off his office's
latest decoration perhaps the most
outwardly strange researcher in
attendance was Kane pathos Crow a
scientist from the foundation's research
Department who had been transformed into
a Labrador Retriever after an experiment
that needless to say went a bit awry
Crow must have been barking up the wrong
tree on that one each of them expressed
their reactions differently deeply
exasperated Dr Sumerian shook his head
and began to question his recent
decision to stop drinking meanwhile Dr
bright looked up at the painting with a
bemused tilting of his head he wondered
if scp-096 would come to kill him and if
it did would it only do so once or would
the creature try again and again each
time that bright inhabited a new body
perhaps in an attempt to look away from
the photo Kane lowered his head and
covered his snout with a paw while Dr
kondraki Hung his head in deep
disappointment the only one among the
group that seemed unaffected by the side
of of the scp-096 photograph was Dr
Charles gears another high-ranking SCP
Foundation scientist it was gears who
finally broke the uncomfortable silence
asking Dr clef the one question that had
been on everyone's Minds why clef
excitedly exclaimed that the photo was
meant to be in celebration of scp-096
finally having been neutralized and
according to the scientists they were
free to look the creature's ugly mug all
they wanted the group stared in horror
at the gaping mouth the screaming
expression of the monster that had
killed so many people not one of them
shared in Dr clef's enthusiasm some like
bright and gear simply argued that the
picture was creepy While others voiced
far greater concerns Kane argued that
putting up a photo of scp-096 was in
poor taste that it was massively
disrespectful to all the unwitting
victims that the shy guy had killed over
the years it was also Reckless and
dangerous Dr Sumerian added it had not
yet been a full 24 hours since scp-09
6's apparent death and if the creature
was somehow able to come back to life it
could kill every researcher in the
office by showing them this so-called
Masterpiece clef had put all of his
co-workers lives at risk he shugged off
their concerns of the creature coming
back to life despite knowing that this
was entirely possible after all wasn't
just anomalies and scps that could defy
death most of the foundation's higher
ranking staff were also capable of the
same even some of the researchers in
that very room had died at least once Dr
clef claimed that should the worst
happen in scp-096 returned to life they
could simply forget its face with
amnestics clef claimed that they were
now free of scp-096's anomalous Powers
thanks to the creature's termination but
the four men and one dog in his office
with him failed to share his enthusiasm
the group then began debating why the
foundation even needed to neutralize
scp-096 in the first place with its
containment purely hinged on nobody ever
looking at the creature he could be
contained by putting a sack over his
head Dr bright pointed out met with
murmurs of agreement from the others
that's where you're wrong jack there
could be photos of him from before he
was contained or someone could get a
hold of the photos we already have of
him Dr clef argued back if they did
something like hack Markiplier's YouTube
account put that photo on the home page
it'd be game over the shy guy would
breach containment with millions of Dash
ones to kill all over the world and that
kind of Rampage would guarantee he'd
have cameras pointed on him 24 7.
exposure would grow exponentially until
the bastard slaughtered most of the
civilization as far as I'm concerned he
should have been classified as ketter
from the Star but bright argued back
stating that the foundation had no real
cause to kill scp-096 they already had a
clear understanding that the Shy Guy's
anomalous behaviors were only even
triggered by somebody observing it and
preventing that from happening was
pretty easy killing the creature just
seemed excessive cruel even Sumerian
chimed in again saying that killing
scp-096 was something the global cult
Coalition would do and the foundation
still hadn't learned all they could
about 096 could someone survive looking
at the Creature if they were in space or
another dimension now no one would ever
know on top of that Dr gears pointed out
that the foundation had no clue what
scp-096's exact origin was where the
creature had come from if it was the
only one of its kind or whether it was a
part of a species of similar monsters if
more beings like the shy guy could exist
in the future they could cause a global
catastrophe but despite all the points
raised by his colleagues Dr klaff didn't
want to hear any of what they had to say
alright I hear what you're all saying
but shut up the shy guy was a Sword of
Damocles dangling over the whole world
we killed him and we're gonna celebrate
that by doing the one thing we could
never do while he was alive looking at
his face each and every day for the rest
of our lives so that we never forget
what we've won and could have lost the
four researchers and the one who had
been turned into a dog all took a moment
to consider clef's argument more
courtesy than he had extended to them
they all looked up at The Haunting
grotesque face of scp-096 once more as
much as they protested the decision to
have the creature killed each of them
secretly hoped it stayed neutralized
especially now that cleff was using
scp-096's photo as an office decoration
if the creature ever managed to come
back anyone that set foot in cleft's
office and looked at the picture was as
good as dead finally Dr kondraki spoke
up and threatened to resign clef to one
of the worst positions imaginable
critiquing first drafts of SCP reports
by Junior researchers for a moment cleff
thought his rival was bluffing but
eventually decided it was better to be
safe than sorry as the gunhow foundation
scientist begrudgingly pulled the photo
from his office wall he muttered to the
group none of you appreciate postmodern
art agent kister was running for his
life every breath had burned in his
throat like inhaling chlorine gas he
sped through the dark surrounded by
deafening metallic screams that bounced
off the eternal of pipes scaling and
strangling the walls around him as far
as he was concerned this was what hell
looked like a nightmare boiler room that
would somehow be less scary if Freddy
Krueger was there because at least
there'd be some kind of recognizably
human intelligence to reason with the
pipes
scp-015 are truly unknowable as an SCP
Foundation mobile Task Force member
agent kister had seen some truly
horrific things in the line of duty he'd
been there during scp-682 containment
breaches firing an assault rifle at the
Beast as it scales hardened into a
bulletproof carapace he'd seen the femur
breaker used on some poor godforsaken
d-class to lure Uncle Larry back into
the containment chamber for some
midnight fun in the most
anxiety-inducing mission of his life he
once even bagged 096's weeping face
after it slaughtered a whole Mountain
Village and these damn pipes were going
to be the thing that killed him he
turned a sharp corner trying to block
out the screams of his teammates four of
them had been sent in the rest were
already dead or Worse stupid stupid
stupid they'd made a classic military
mistake underestimating the capabilities
of their enemy and an agent kister's
experience this had always been a
capital offense all to install that
machine that stupid little remote
control reconnaissance vehicle that's
what they'd given their lives for agent
kister tried to Blink away the memory of
agent Montgomery's Face Monty was the
youngest member of the team 28 years old
his first major mission Into the Heart
of a skip kister wanted to remember him
how he'd first seen him a bright-eyed
greenhorn ready to protect the human
race from the horrors that lay in the
dark but he'd been the first to go when
everything got
f-u-b-a-r it was the smaller pipes that
got Monty four of them shot out spearing
his lungs and heart pinning him in place
even if they tried to cut him out he
would have been a goner he coughed up
blood and went ghosts white faster than
you'd ever imagined kister would never
forget For What Little time he had left
to live the horrible sight of the light
leaving that kid's eyes and all this
because one of them had tripped on one
of the pipes on the way out and busted
it the mission was already done what an
awful pointless way to die kister was
yanked from his aching Thoughts by a
sudden obstacle in the way a huge
towering pipe that looked like a pillar
of Flesh covered in bulbous staring eyes
the thought crossed his mind Jesus these
pipes can really be made out of anything
he looked down and saw a series of
rubber pipes slithering towards his feet
along the ground like snakes it was time
to run again but how long could you even
run for when the very location around
you wants you dead they should have sent
the mole rats for a job like this the
infinitely reconfiguring pipes changed
the layout of the way Warehouse around
him making Escape seem all the more
unfeasible that's when he started
thinking about the terrible thing that
happened to agent green when 015 turned
hostile they needed to make a run for it
fast it wasn't unlike being a pathogen
inside a living body you start to make
trouble and the body's immune system is
going to come for you and one of the
most common mechanisms for a body
fighting a virus is a fever a sudden
increase in temperature that burns out
the threat the group turned and ran as
the pipes started twisting towards them
agent green panicked and began striking
at the pipes around him with his hands
the first instinct would have been to
shoot but no guns were permitted inside
the scp-015 warehouse it reacted
severely to any kind of tool being
brought into its proximity several dead
agents and researchers could tell you
all about this if they hadn't made that
same mistake but when things were
already going sideways it left them
defenseless agent green was soon boxed
in caged by a latticework of pipes in
varying sizes he tried desperately to
push them out of the way and make an
Escape Route but the hissing noise was
getting louder and louder as the pipes
started to turn a glowing red all around
him after all when a body needs to deal
with a hostile foreign object it burns
out the threat kister wished he could
shake the awful high-pitched whale that
agent green made while the heat inside
his pipe cage became unbearable it was
like seeing a human get caught inside a
giant bug zapper his skin went black and
charred and soon after the heat had
risen to such an insane degree that
agent green was reduced to little more
than Ash in his pipe furnace but kister
couldn't afford to dwell he kept running
vaulting over a long ragged pipe made
from stinking human hair this terrible
Place stank of motor oil mold and death
but maybe those perceptions had been
colored by the Terrible Things he'd seen
here there was again that awful choked
screaming coming from inside the pipes
agent Boggs it was a nightmare to hear
him shriek like that Boggs had been one
of the toughest men that kissed her had
ever met he mentored him back when he
first became an MTF member having bogs
on the team meant experience had been
safety it meant that things would go
okay kister had seen Boggs stare down
some of the most horrifying skips
imaginable and not even Flinch and yet
here he was
screaming and bawling like a hurt child
in the pipes Boggs was the next one to
get taken as he and kissed her ran
through the dark trying to find a way
out they'd passed a huge pipe made of a
soft foam-like substance a seam in the
side of the pipe had yawned open and a
tangle of writhing tentacles each one
Barbed with thorns like the stem of a
rose bush they enveloped agent Boggs
cutting into his weathered skin he
gasped in pain unable to scream it
happened so fast before Kester even had
a chance to grab him he was pulled into
the pipe and the crevice sealed behind
him and that was when the screaming
really started for poor agent Boggs
kister hoped for his sake that he would
die sometime soon shrouded in the fog of
his dark thoughts agent kister turned a
corner and felt cold hard metal suddenly
collided with his face breaking his nose
with an unpleasant crunch he'd been
clotheslined by a low pipe that hadn't
been there before and now he was laid
out on his back face humming with pain
thoughts and feelings swam he looked up
into these seemingly infinite web of
pipes weaving through the air above him
he was right earlier he just knew it the
place was held it'd be his eternal
resting place suddenly a new huge shape
moved into the space above him a pipe of
ancient rusty iron that looked older
than even the warehouse holding this
whole mess right above him there was a
huge valve fixed into the pipe's belly
he watched helpless as the valve opened
itself with a squeal and a huge Dark
Mask came pouring out of it onto his
body a sudden weight a sudden warmth
sound and movement and Tiny scratching
claws rats thousands of big hungry black
rats with gnarled yellow teeth clumps of
fur Purge from their skin by mange big
ropey worm-like Tails swaying and
whipping at the air who knows how long
they've been in that pipe who knows when
these rats had eaten anything that
wasn't their brothers and sisters and
here was agent kister given unto them by
the Glorious pipes the last thing he
ever saw were those nasty yellow teeth
because they ate his eyes first word of
the four disappeared and presumed dead
operatives soon reached Dr Charles Ogden
gears the legendarily tack turned senior
researcher that managed the scp-015
project among a myriad of others his
face didn't betray a flicker of emotion
when he was informed about the men lost
to
scp-015 it wasn't that he didn't feel
for them nor that he deemed it both
unproductive and unprofessional to dwell
on the deaths of personnel when carrying
out their duties after all being killed
by an anomaly was simply an occupational
hazard and a generous stipend would be
sent to their families to compensate for
their tragic loss Dr gears simply asked
was the mission successful in spite of
the casualties did the team manage to
install the module robotic vehicle at
the epicenter he was told that the mrv
had been successfully installed at least
Dr gears nodded and began scheduling a
second exploratory mission for a few
months in the future to check the status
of the machine still in the meantime the
mrv would chug along doing what humans
couldn't or perhaps shouldn't do within
the nightmarish mess of ever-growing
pipes it would roll through collecting
information on everything around it
hopefully giving the SCP Foundation an
in-road to mapping the whole thing
without needing to send a convocative
staff Into the Danger Zone just to
discover more about these peculiar pipes
sure some lives were lost getting in
there but this measure would likely save
even more lives in the long run that was
until something went wrong the exact
nature of what happened to the mrv
inside the domain of pipes was a mystery
but it wasn't doing its intended job and
the SC EP Foundation needed to find out
why the second exploratory mission was
required much sooner than they'd
initially anticipated with a dual
purpose collecting the readings and
finding out what exactly had happened to
the mrv in the first place they included
a more specific set of instructions for
the next mission only three members of
personnel to enter
scp-015 this time to minimize potential
loss one trained technician to collect
and read the Diagnostics and two guards
to maintain discipline and safety under
pressure with a setup like that what
could possibly go wrong Dr gears's
various assistants began headhunting the
perfect team for the job Junior
researcher Lon wanting to prove herself
and climb up the ranks put her name
forward she was young intelligent and
had the initiative to get the job done
though there was one thing that she
hadn't disclosed when she was applying
for this important new position Junior
researcher Lawns suffered from
claustrophobia the fear of enclosed
spaces then the hunt was on for the two
members of foundation military personnel
who'd escort lawn to the mrv to take the
readings like the two priests in The
Exorcist they decided to recruit one
grizzled experienced operative and one
extremely cautious Young Buck straight
out of the foundation MTF Training
Academy the younger of the two
operatives codenamed agent 2 was careful
and conscientious to a fault he did
things by the book or not at all the
older operative codenamed agent 6 was
quite the opposite he done this job long
enough to operate solely on Instinct and
resented his employers for expecting him
to approach his missions any other way
long agent 2 and agent 6. the team was
assembled and when the time came they
were taken to scp-015 to execute their
mission it should have been simple
enough get in collect the readings and
get that count though a few weeks
earlier the same thing would have been
said for the mission to install the mrv
which left for mobile task force
operatives dead or Worse nothing was
ever as simple as it seemed when it came
to
scp-015 they were only allowed
flashlights inside anything else carried
a substantial risk of activating
scp-015's defensive State putting all of
their lives in Jeopardy Bond had tried
to keep things light masking her own
terrible fear at this strange news
situation she joked that perhaps the
three of them should get Mario hats
seeing as they were plumbers now agent 2
happily laughed along suggesting that
perhaps he should be Luigi agent 6 was
utterly unamused by this whole situation
and wanted no part of it which is
honestly just so Wario of him they
followed along a carefully mapped route
through the pipes being careful not to
touch any of them after all you never
know what could set scp-015 off agent 6
didn't share in their merriment or their
concern in fact he had contempt for them
and this whole situation he thought lawn
and agent 2 were a pair of frightened
skittish children willing to buy
whatever foundation-assigned bull honky
they were given he didn't believe that
scp-015 was anywhere near as dangerous
as they'd been told in all likelihood
knowing the Eggheads up top they just
didn't want men of action like him
breaking any of their precious little
toys while conducting missions on their
behalf this whole thing was a big stupid
joke as they ducked and weaved through
the confines of scp-015 the tensions
between them all just silently grew
their flashlights played among the pipes
revealing the insane variety of shapes
sizes compositions and materials in here
wood steel flesh bone glass pressed Ash
granite and so much more and yet there
were no pipes surprised of any standard
pipe making material like lead PVC
plastic or copper it was undeniably
freaky but when you work with scps for
long enough you learn to stop asking
questions about the more minor forms of
strangeness inherent to anomalies the
composition only got narrower as they
delved deeper into the warehouse Vaughn
felt the anxiety like a hand gripping
her throat and squeezing but trying
still to keep it hidden agent 6 the
largest among them almost got stuck a
few times trying to crawl into spaces
too tight for him to fit he felt like
murdering lawn when she threw out a
casual comparison to Winnie the Pooh in
the process when they reached the mrv it
gave them an ounce of momentary relief
the journey was halfway done but the
Comfort was quickly squashed by seeing
what had actually happened to the mrv it
had been speared by a pipe and new pipes
had grown through and out of it
effectively rooting it in place this
caused immediate debate among the group
around one key issue did this mean that
the mrv was now technically part of the
pipes and by extension would the pipes
feel the need to defend themselves if
the data banks were removed from the mrv
in order to deliver the readings back to
the researchers at site 17. while lawn
and agent 2 carefully discussed the
issue agent 6 lost his temper and
decided to show these two foolish kids
how it was done he claimed the two of
them were worrying about a bunch of
foundation Hui that they were an
experienced and gullible enough to
believe as if this bunch of weird pipes
was actually dangerous it was like how
every six anomalies there's Apparently
one capable of ending the world it's all
a bunch of overblown fear-mongering
nonsense and to prove that he wasn't
just all talk on this front agent 6
pried open the top of the mrv and slid
out the data cards which seemed to be
covered in some kind of viscous
unpleasant liquid from the pipes that
had penetrated the device still he'd
gotten what they came for he could have
done this whole thing alone without this
pair of bedwetters he scoffed and said
kids I don't know how you two survive
but he shouldn't have spoken so soon the
large pipe that he didn't even realize
he was standing on opened up beneath his
feet and seconds later he was immersed
up to his shoulders in it six began to
let out the most horrifying shrieks
you've ever heard and when agent 2 and
Lawn ran over to try and help him out
they realized why the pipe below agent 6
was filled with flowing molten Iron by
the time they pulled agent 6 out well
agent 6 from the shoulders up
considering that that was all that was
left he was already dead and despite the
actual aggressor being destroyed
scp-015 wasn't done it was ready to
clean house as agent 2 and Lon attempted
to flee some eye level pipes around them
burst firing crystallized glass into
their faces cutting into their skin and
eyes but they needed to push on despite
the pain if they wanted to survive and
get out the two of them ran horrifying
noises of twisting and bursting pipes
roaring behind them pipes made of thorns
and Bones started to grow blocking off
their exits until they were trapped Bond
utilizing her small frame was able to
crawl through a gap in the pipes into an
adjoining chamber two was given a
horrifying surprise when a pipe burst
near his hand showering his flesh in
thick corrosive Gunk his hand melted
away at the wrist as long called for
help in the tiny cram chamber she was
locked in two ran off to try and find an
exit where he could bring more people in
to help them but it would already be too
late for poor lawn a thick honey-like
substance began bleeding into the
chamber disgusting in its overpowering
saccharine flavor and goopy viscous
thickness the chamber seemed to get
smaller and smaller as Lon screamed as
the honey level Rose eventually it got
higher than her mouth and nose could
reach she gave a horrifying final gurgle
and then she was gone entombed forever
between the pipes agent 2 kept running
his flashlight was beginning to die but
he didn't care as his eyes bled from the
splinters of glass and what was left of
his hand dripped from the jagged nub of
his wrist all he could do was keep
moving forwards he panted and screamed
and stumbled in the dark until he
tripped on something he didn't notice
and pitched forwards he tumbled into the
gaping maw of a nearby pipe surrounded
by unseeable unknowable ooze as he
tumbled further down into the seemingly
infinite Darkness it was too dark to see
and too cramped to move anywhere but
straight down all he could do was scream
and scream and scream until his voice
was hoarse and his throat bled though
nobody was there to even hear his cries
days later when his skin started to
shred off it was almost welcome Dr gears
would later receive the news of this
tragically failed Mission and the of
three operatives now declared Mia
because of it he sighed and wrote up his
report on the matter closing with the
sentence data deemed non-vital and might
have lost staff
scp-015 classification level review
suggested drip drip drip if you see The
Telltale black mucus dripping from the
wall behind you splattering down from
the ceiling then it is already too late
for you the plaster will start to split
the wood will warp and rot metal will
Rust you should try to run attempt to
hide but know that he is coming for you
the old man limping along relentlessly
never stopping to rest to eat to catch
his breath he has no need for such human
things anymore you can't fight him you
can't reason with him and you can't kill
what might as well already be dead just
when you think you've found a safe place
place to hide you'll hear a creaking
from the floor below you a blinding pain
as something sharp slashes through your
Achilles tendon is the last thing you
will feel before the decrepit nightmare
Vision drags you to his lair never to
return even if you could Escape now the
sickness is already in you skin already
slackening and muscles beginning to
liquefy he is rot he is death he is the
disintegration of all hope and light and
he has made you his prey we've covered
scp-106 or the old man before we've
talked about his abilities his hunting
patterns an incident in which he escaped
and a variety of theories regarding his
origin it is unknown for sure where
exactly the old man came from there are
three major theories as to his true
origin which created one of the most
fearsome anomalies the SCP Foundation
has ever come across perhaps he was a
deeply Disturbed World War 1 soldier who
gazed too long into something better
left untouched perhaps he was never
human at all but instead a Divergent
humanoid species that preyed on early
prehistoric mankind today we're focusing
on the third possibility and arguably
the most tragic of the three it begins
with another man we've covered on the
channel before named Dr Robert Scranton
and his wife Dr Anna Lang you probably
know them for two things the Scranton
reality anchor and The Accidental
discovery of scp-3001 or the red reality
in case you haven't seen our video on
the subject here's a brief recap of the
whole unfortunate affair on January 2nd
2000 at site 120 Robert and Anna were
hard at work as the head researchers
developing an experimental device known
as The Lang Scranton stabilizer the LSS
was intended to work as a reality anchor
but it was in its early stages and still
unstable a seismic event Rock the
research site damaging several LSS units
and creating a wormhole that transported
Dr Scranton to the pocket Dimension
Hereafter referred to as
scp-3001 this little pocket of space
this impossible world just adjacent to
ours has some unusual properties it
causes matter within it to deteriorate
as its Hume level approaches that of the
environment Humes being the measurement
unit for reality stability Robert
Scranton was trapped there in the red
reality alive for a terrifyingly long
time five years 11 months and 21 days
before the logs he kept ended there he
struggled to hold on to himself he
grasped desperately at shreds of his
Humanity his memories even as the world
around him slowly ate them away finally
only one thing remained Anna his wife he
could just barely remember her name
remember that he wanted to get back to
her the was a brief moment of Hope on
December 23 2005 when the LSS control
panel reappeared in a Testing Lab at
site-120 Dr Anna Lang arrived to monitor
the situation a massive bloody organic
matter appeared alongside it and as Anna
called out for her lost love something
clattered to the floor and broke her
heart her husband's wedding ring stained
with unidentified organic matter
smelling of black blood and spoiled meat
she collapsed under the weight of the
possibility that her husband was no
longer lost in a physical sense but in
another sense entirely that this mass of
Flesh unrecognizable as human might be
the man she once loved tying his
favorite tie for him on date nights
dancing drunkenly to Living on a Prayer
collapsing on the couch together
breathless with laughter and the sheer
Joy of one another that he could be both
here at last but Gone Forever Dr Anna
Lang was taken to the medical Bay and
treated for Shaw years passed after
Ana's last encounter with her husband
she carried the ring with her in her
pocket every day for the first few after
five years she threaded the chain
through it wearing it around her neck
under her clothes after 10 more years
she stopped noticing it was even on
anymore it had become a part of her
engraved on her heart with the memories
of the man she had loved lost and
grieved with nothing to go home to at
the end of the day no one to share her
time off with Anna began to pour herself
deeper into her work she would never
remarry she knew that Robert had been
the only man for her now there was only
her commitment to the foundation and the
research she did there and the silent
promise she made to herself that she
would never let anything like the events
of January 2nd 2000 happen again but
will they with no reason to go home
Anna's nights at the lab grew later and
later her colleagues often joke that she
might as well sleep there since that was
the only thing she went home to do this
sadness behind her eyes tended to cut
their jokes short soon after making them
though Anna liked the late night work
the lab was still almost Serene she
could disappear into the research the
calculations let them take over and
quite the noise in her mind the lights
were dimmed no one was asking her a name
questions or bustling around while she
tried to focus there was nothing but her
notes and textbooks the light of her
lone desk lamp glowing softly in the
dark and the work it was one of these
late nights buried in a mountain of
paperwork that Anna began to hear a
strange sound she didn't notice it at
first absorbed as she was in a sea of
calculations but soon it began to
permeate the room breaking through her
focus a rustling sound a crackling of
sorts quietly murmuring into her ears
though she was vaguely aware of it the
way you might be aware of the wind
rustling through the trees outside your
bedroom window she didn't truly hear it
until she smelled something faint but
foul it was no matter how muted the
unmistakable scent of rot she stepped
down from her lab stool her joints
creaking with effort as she worked out
the stiffness in her muscles she
adjusted her glasses peering into the
shadows for the source of the sound but
saw nothing of note she took a step
forward into the dark then another and
then another behind her the desk lamp
flickered then cut out entirely she
stopped blinking in the sudden complete
darkness and sudden silence the noise
had stopped the only sound was her
breathing quickened with fear she pulled
the phone from her pocket and turned on
its flashlight using its weak beam to
light her way she turned back to her
desk looking for the issue that caused
the light to cut out perhaps a short in
the wire or a bulb that needed changing
before she could take a look at the lamp
however something else caught her eye
there was something slick and red on her
stack of papers dripping onto the clean
white surface and staining it with Gore
a closer look revealed what it was and a
shiver ran down her spine a kidney fresh
and human she couldn't bring herself to
touch it but somehow knew that if she
did it would be
her heart pounding and her suddenly
tightening chest as the noise resumed
behind her wet slapping louder than
before her feet moved on their own
accord as she walked toward the sound
holding the flashlight in front of her
in a shaking hand the black wall of the
lab illuminated by the light was smeared
with something dark and strange slick
like oil but with a rotten smell a
closer look revealed that the wall
itself was beginning to change drooping
limply like wet cardboard she froze
watching helplessly as the wall bubbled
crumbling to Pieces suddenly a hand
emerged from the wall gray skin slick
with black fluid its fingers
surprisingly strong gripped her arm she
tore it away scrambling back and saw
that pieces of her lab coat had come off
melting into the gray skin of the alien
hand as the arm reached for her again
she stumbled and dropped her phone on
the floor casting its light against the
wall and the figure worming its way out
there it was an old man naked and gray
slimy decaying skin coming off in pieces
its throat was shredded an open wound
and a grinned at her with stiff
shriveled lips stretched over blackened
teeth its eyes were the worst part even
admits the rest of the Walking Corpse
they were almost like a man's they were
correct in shape and placement but they
were wrong they were empty clouded over
and void of any warmth or Mercy as he
stood there the ground beneath him began
to dissipate melting into an oily puddle
that enveloped her phone and stuffed out
its light there was only one thing left
for Anna to do and so she ran she turned
and made a break for the lab doors lungs
burning from the effort she cried out
for the guard on night Duty Frank her
voice was shrill and pleading he
appeared from around the corner gun
already drawn eyes wide and alert at the
Panic he must have heard in her voice as
Frank tried to calm her down and she
tried desperately to explain what she
had seen the old man forced his way
through the lab doors leaving a trail of
corrosive black slime in his this wake
Frank fired his gun hitting the old man
in the chest twice he collapsed sinking
into the floor as his excretion broke
away the tiles beneath him as Anna and
Frank debated what to do next a drip of
black mucus landed on Frank's radio from
above another drop fell Landing directly
in his eye he screamed in agony the
mucus dissolving his eyeball on contact
next the empty grin appeared through the
ceiling and the old man fell on top of
Frank tearing out his throat with its
bare hands Anna knew that she had to
escape but where could she go she
couldn't think couldn't plan she just
knew she had to run she ran until her
feet suddenly stopped obeying she was
stuck she was sinking into the ground
and then she was falling down down into
a moldy Dusty hallway dark except for a
nauseating greenish gray glow she had
been pulled into some new nightmarish
world she ran through a nearby door and
found herself shockingly in her old
apartment how had she gotten here how
did the old man know this place there
was her bed her desk her closet she
flung open the closet door to find a
pile of rotten corpses that poured out
and slopped onto the floor she covered
her mouth to choke back a scream turned
and fled then she was back in the hall
this time she recognized it it was a
twisted warped version of sight 120. in
front of her there he was the old man
had found her again and now she was in
his territory he stared at her with
those Hollow eyes and for the first time
spoke
he growled she stopped in her tracks
Frozen to the spot what he said next
turned her stomach and brought tears to
her eyes
he knew her name again he repeated
he reached out to her with a hand that
had a tan line where a wedding ring had
one spin the same ring burning against
her skin under her shirt he cupped her
cheek and she felt the skin sting and
blister he kissed her her teeth melting
infusing tongue turning to Mush but
dribbled down her throat and choked her
her last thought through the fear and
despair was the ache of love her husband
was not lost he was found and he had
found her too now they would be together
forever the SCP Foundation is well aware
of the Thin Line separating itself
between normalcy and the end of the
human race how easily that balance can
be upset and the foundation overturned
without the foundation we may be subject
to any number of scenarios that may
result in our untimely Extinction the
reign of the Scarlet King ready to
enslave the world once more the
assimilation of the broken God an
Ascension of humanity into a most
perfect machine the SCP Foundation is
often outmatched and outnumbered
competing against ancient unspeakable
Horrors but those anomalies are well
known one could almost say that they're
built up and that the foundation knows
the risks that can lie ahead in the
future in other words they have time to
prepare but when dealing with the
anomalous the unexpected is bound to
occur it's part of what the SCP
Foundation deals with and an element of
their work they've forever been unable
to control or predict the anomalous is
Untamed it occurs without Rhyme or
Reason in the world of the SCP
Foundation it is entirely possible you
might wake up and find that everyone
around you has died or that the world's
been consumed by an evil unseen force
and there would be nothing you can do
about it it happened and not even the
foundation was able to stop it perhaps
the overabundance and unpredictable
ability of the world is why the
foundation deemed it necessary to build
scp-2000 the machine capable of
restarting civilization from scratch
death and mass destruction is always at
the door of the foundation and sometimes
they are unable to prevent it we've
previously looked at the tale of Pietro
Wilson who found himself in a world
devastated by an unknown entity but
scp-5000 is far from the only time the
foundation has dealt with the anomalous
apocalypse today we're going to be
telling a story of
scp-1915 and an entity known only as the
absence it's a story you may not have
heard before and like all stories
involving the SCP Foundation and the end
of the world we look forward to telling
it for centuries civilizations have been
predicting the end of the world from the
Mayans to the ancient Greeks to the
biblical and Disney preachers of today
Humanity seems obsessed with trying to
figure out the when and how of its
Extinction but when the day data
eventually comes we all find ourselves
in the exact same place healthy and
Alive none of us actually expect such an
event to happen and if it did most of us
realize that we wouldn't be among the
survivors who could witness the world
after it was empty but for scp-1915 that
was not the case
scp-1915 stood alone in the desert
listening to The Silence of the evening
Sunset if he hadn't known what had
happened to the world he could call the
scene beautiful or Serene he might find
it pure but he couldn't allow himself to
enjoy the calming Vistas not after what
he had witnessed he knew What Lies
Beneath and among the Sands of that
desert he knew the feeling of seven
billion human Souls being ground up
stretched thin and buried below without
any trace of their existence remaining
and he knew this was because he was the
only one who put them there it's quiet
out here
scp-1915 thought to himself how other it
all happened so fast once we're gone but
let's turn back the clock a bit who is
scp-1915 how did he get himself into
this situation the foundation's database
holds the answers
scp-1915 was a humanoid entity contained
in a standard humanoid chamber which it
had modified itself
scp-1915's containment procedures stated
that furniture and sustenance were
unnecessary as scp-1915 provided both of
them itself
scp-1915 looked like a completely
average middle-aged white male the type
you'd pass by on the street and neglect
to notice he was of unexceptional build
and height and public records gave him
an equally unexceptional name which has
been lost due to years of the
foundation's redaction and information
suppression thankfully for the
foundation a background check into
scp-1915 civilian life revealed no
friends or relatives meaning that
removing scp-1950 15 from society was as
easy as it first appeared
scp-1915 is so far relatively
unremarkable and that's entirely the
point
scp-1915's anomalous nature lies in its
ability to prevent any significant
long-term change to its body personality
memory or lifestyle
scp-1915 is also a reality bender and it
will actively alter the world around it
to maintain its personal status quo
though these alterations are largely
limited to non-living matter
manipulation and mental manipulations as
far as reality vendors go
scp-1915 is relatively weak as it is
unable to permanently affect living
creatures with its anomalous abilities
other than itself what makes
scp-1915 especially interesting and
especially dangerous as well is the fact
that it is entirely unaware of its own
anomalous nature its mild discontent
expressed in interviews with the
foundation suggested to the organized
that scp-1915 has little if any control
over its own abilities
scp-1915 is due to its anomalous nature
entirely unaware of its containment as
being locked up by the SCP Foundation
would definitely be a significant
long-term change in fact it still
believes that it is employed by a
corporation and working a mundane office
job where the foundation recovered
scp-1915 originally
scp-1915 cannot bring itself to accept
its situation and as instead
unconsciously altered its mind and
containment cell accordingly to scp-1915
absolutely nothing has changed during
its initial recovery from its office job
scp-1915 altered the mobile task Force's
armored vehicle into a city bus and
convinced itself that the operatives
escorting it were simply other civilians
on their commute to work once it arrived
at site 17
scp-1915 converted its contain
attainment cell into an exact replica of
its apartment complete with electronic
devices akin to the ones it owned
running water and sewage access it even
assumed the other researchers and guards
inside the facility were neighbors or
local service workers the morning
following its containment
scp-1915 left itself despite it being
locked and entered a maintenance closet
the closet was transformed into a
recreation of the office cubicle
scp-1915 worked in prior to being
contained when Foundation researchers
tried to communicate with scp-1915 it
apologized for coming after hours to
finish the budget report claiming that
it needed the extra income during an
interview with the foundation
scp-1915 still couldn't accept its
situation instead it believed that it
was being referred to by name despite
being referred to as
scp-1915 and that it was still working
an office job it displayed remorse that
it was passed over for a promotion yet
again and asked the interview or if it
was working on the third floor
scp-1915 was completely and utterly
unable to view reality outside of its
own lens sure he's able to alter reality
but he's entirely unaware of it in a way
the only thing keeping scp-1915 chained
to that soul-sucking office job is
itself and its inability to accept
anything different what a metaphor right
but how could
scp-1915 defy reality in the face of the
world ending would he still believe that
he's working away at a budget report or
grabbing coffee for his boss when the
world's burning around him let's move
back to the desert scene where scp-1915
is standing before an empty World
seemingly holding itself responsible for
ridding the Earth of humanity
scp-1915 recollects what occurred the
events leading up to this moment he
thinks of what happened when staring
outside the windows of its containment
cell apartment
scp-1915 remembers what it saw it began
the day a you you that I have never
known found my power the power I hid
from myself in some previous life for
reasons I can now easily guess I was
looking out of the window of my
apartment so I could see the stars and
instead I saw you blazing as you tore
yourself asunder to keep the power away
from yourself you didn't trust what you
would do with it and so you chose to
throw it away you knew yourself all too
well and I suspect I did too at one
point by all accounts I should not have
been able to see you for my apartment
was truly a tiny containment cell about
a half mile underground but such
considerations never meant much to one
living entity in his own world when I
saw the moment of your demise I became
aware of myself for the first time and I
have no idea in how long whichever part
of me that led me to throw away my power
did the same to my will trapping it in
an internal status quo for which there
could be no release an eternity of
filing spreadsheets from employers who
existed solely in my head of nine
o'clock meetings with no one of fake
crushes over imaginary women an eternity
of tired grinding mediocrity but that
was over that night with your soul
burning in the atmosphere like the
loneliest of stars I awakened I died
whatever
scp-1915 saw that day made it aware of
the farce of a life that it had created
for itself and beneath those feelings of
Conformity there was sadness but
whatever left that little cell turned
apartment wasn't me anymore I was never
more than an earthworm distinct from all
the rest only that I had a little more
control over the soil in which I crawled
they never thought me more than a minor
reality Bender a bundle of introverted
powers and neuroses that was very
unlikely to ever pose any serious threat
and they were right the person I was as
CP 1915 as they called me never was
anything other than that but 1915 died
that day a watching a falling star
realizing that it had been cheated lied
to and the crushing reality of its
current situation
scp-1915 lashed out against the
foundation the thing that then swatted
the guards posed at its cell like there
were little less than Nets the Rays site
17 into this fine white sand that was
now so warm beneath the feet that was
something else not an entity for that
would imply a personality and this thing
surely has none not a purpose for there
was no purpose behind its action then
nor will there be for any of its actions
to come nor was it a will for wants
nothing not Vengeance not Dominion not
Freedom not even simple power no if I
had to describe that thing as anything
at all it would be a an absence a void
where the entity should be a lack of
purpose an imbecile Force devoid of all
will and absence scp-1915
add in its realization become an absence
perhaps realizing the meaninglessness of
its own self-contained life it took out
that absence of feeling onto the world
and with scp-1915's absence came
Humanity's absence as well like nothing
had ever happened
scp-1915 had created an absence of
humanity it had erased everything but
the Sun the desert and itself and now it
stood alone in an empty lonely world it
continued to think to itself remembering
how it caused the downfall of the SCP
Foundation so easily after site 17's
destruction retaliation soon followed
standard containment teams at first
though certainly still enough to meet
any anomaly the foundation imagine could
be contained in site-17 with
overwhelming Force when those men failed
to return fail to even report to their
arrival more serious measures had to be
taken sight 17 has always been isolated
and so so they could act freely gunships
and fire teams Ariel bombardment and
artillery barrages the foundation came
down on what it's still believed to be
SCP in 1915 like a fire God's fist all
heat and sound and Bluster had it still
been truly corporeal I doubt even ashes
would have remained but whatever the
absence truly was by that point the
tattered semblance of My Flesh hanging
around it had very little to do with it
it simply stood there and took it all in
and the foundation's initial Fury was
soon spent it then began to walk and not
too quickly either the days it simply
leisurely Strode on while the foundation
threw everything it had of it I watched
from within my deadbolt as it walked
unfeeling uncaring and this desert
followed in its wake as inscruciable and
Unstoppable as it's harming her while
the foundation and the rest of humanity
were decimated quite easily there was
some Immortal beings that SCP 1915 was
aware it could not fully erase other
anomalies that the foundation had
contained somewhat but they were all but
remained tied to a dead and desolate
World
scp-1915's memories continued when
someone walks they are bound to reach
somewhere eventually despite everyone's
best efforts and so the absence arrived
at its first city the Sands at its heels
like an obedient lap dog oh there have
been Villages and towns before that but
the absence didn't seem to care enough
to bother with them it simply walked by
leaving them to the whims of the Sands
which were only ever singular in their
intent but through the streets of the
city it Strode has mobile task forces
fought and fell to buy the civilian
population just a few more minutes to
evacuate by this point hiding what was
truly going on became impossible of
course as Street after streets sank
beneath the gentle crawling tide the
foundation had of course attempted to
evacuate the city once it realized there
was no stopping the absence but if I've
learned anything in my eons as a
corporeal peon is that organizing an
operation of that magnitude is something
that takes a lot more time than the
foundation had it's wonder they managed
to save as many as they did City to City
town to town
scp-1915 continued on a war path turning
its surroundings to dust the Earth
became the desert that it now stood in
in one moment a city of 500 000 existed
and the next it didn't
scp-1915 could not explain it instead it
simply was and was not the foundation as
scp-1915 recalled was becoming desperate
and it began to turn to various groups
of interest for Health it was then I
believe that the foundation realized
that it could not stand alone the next
few months of the absences March saw
them turn to their sometimes allies
Coalition Mage killers and thermonuclear
strikes initiative paladins and holy
relics sniper rifle or sacred sword
burning Inferno or divine retribution
the absence did not care and soon the
foundation had no allies left to turn to
it then called on its once vicious
enemies ink eaters wove their art in
maddening patterns to break the minds of
the infinite archivists and Librarians
poured from the ways bringing with them
the knowledge of a hundred thousand
worlds Clockwork Titans shook the barren
whiteness of the Sands with the Thunder
of metal the absence did not care and
soon the foundation ran out of enemies
in an act of desperation they then
committed their most painful betrayal
the wardens Unleashed upon the world
their prisoners of these I have made
note though I doubt the absence did the
same with the anomalous objects it once
contained now released the foundation
used its own SCP objects against
scp-1915 in an effort to stop the entity
from destroying the world itself Health
scp-1915 recalled fighting against
scp-073 and
scp-076 the brothers Kane and Abel have
recalled scp-343 The Entity claiming to
be the abrahamic god launching an
assault of earth-shattering Destruction
and divine wrath but 343 nor the
brothers were able to match
scp-1915 when they stared into SCP in
1915's lack of a gaze they all faded
into nothing much like the rest of the
world that had turned to dust as a
result of the absence
scp-1915 then recalled encountering two
forms of
scp-2845 the god panglos both of which
were powerful Mighty and all-consuming
but they had formed and they're being
knelt before
scp-1915 like everything else did the
absence withstood their presence like it
had done with everything before them for
years the foundation continued to send
every anomaly in its possession after
scp-1915 but they paled in comparison to
the power of the absence and eventually
the foundation was out of anomalies the
foundation was out of time as well
scp-1915s marched to the ends of the
Earth brought it to a single remaining
human settlement a coalition of
survivors that had cooped themselves up
in hopes of outrunning the entity some
were former agents of the foundation
others were members of various groups of
interest but as you might have expected
they didn't hold a candle to scp-1915 in
an act of defiance against the world
that it had been keeping itself from
scp-1915 wiped the city from the earth
and then it was truly alone and now all
scp-1915 had to do was think back to
what had occurred and how much longer
the rest of the universe had before it
too succumbed to the absence quiet small
bereft of heroics and great Deeds free
of pretensions of great meaning one
night there was a human race on the
planet Earth the next there wasn't and
that was that the stars do not wait for
you brother when you took my power when
you burned yourself in the skies above
they looked upon you and felt nothing
the stars did not wait for Humanity for
all the promise it showed for all the
promise others saw on them but what of
the absence what if me We Are I Am by
all accounts and possible qualifications
the greatest monster this world has ever
saw perhaps that any world saw and yet
brother I see now that the Stars wait
for us for me where is the Justice in
that seek it not for there is none but
the fact remains brother the stars do
not wait for you but they wait for me to
take them into My Embrace I suspect I
shall not be long welcome dear viewers
to another tale of excitement in
Intrigue from The Archives of the SCP
Foundation today we're covering A
peculiar story titled Foundation
facilities and how to loot them our
story opens on shock a member of
scp-4799 frantically running for her
life
scp-4799 in case you aren't already
aware is a group of Smugglers also known
by the name Mariachis Merchants now the
merchants aren't your average every day
under the table Traders mind you this
group is capable of trans-universal
travel stealing advanced technology from
other universes members of Mariachi's
Merchants will then sell these devices
to turn a profit each of these members
of which there are believed to be seven
originally come from a separate Universe
outside of our own and shock she's one
of the best blaster in her hand shock
ran down the corridor stopping at a
t-shaped intersection frantically trying
to decide which way to turn next the
energy weapon in her hand was still warm
to the touch she'd only just fired it
down to the last 12 shots 13. if she was
lucky there was only meant to be one
life form nearby the only other living
thing in a two kilometer radius but
chalk had quickly learned that she was
far from alone two things wearing lab
coats things that had perhaps once been
human beings were shambling their way
closer to her the nearest door was
locked protected by a keypad but there
was no time to hack her way inside
letting out a growl shock turned and
opened fire on her pursuers the pair of
creatures that hadn't registered as life
forms but were still inexplicably alive
energy bolts spat from her Blaster
disintegrating them both in an instant
turning her Focus to the nearby door
shock pushed a thin black device into a
key card slot connected to a thin screen
that controlled it she grumbled about
how what had seemed like a simple
Scavenging Mission had gone South so
quickly the planet appeared to be dead
at least from the perspective of the
Mariachi's merchant ship in orbit what
was the worst that could happen turns
out losing communication with her crew
for one they'd been radio silent after
the ship was reportedly fired upon the
merchants had promised to come back for
shock once they'd shaken off whoever was
shooting at them the facility she was
trying to scavenge had once belonged to
the SCP Foundation presumably a long
time ago codenamed site 101 built under
a spacecraft launch compound it should
have been a gold mine filled with all
sorts of valuable technology but so far
it didn't seem like there was anything
left in the facility that justified the
dangerous trip the keypad flashed green
as the door unlocked Shaw collected up
her hacking device as the door opened
and one of the creatures appeared on the
other side reacting with Incredible
speed shock blasted the creature into
dust cursing at its body as it
disintegrated Adam by Adam what were
these things and why did the merchant
sensors not read them as life forms she
pushed the question to the back of her
mind there was a time and place to
contemplate what could be classified as
alive and this was neither hurtling down
on the newly opened Corridor shock
headed towards an open office door
hiding as quietly as possible in the
office making sure the door was secure
enough that those Horrors outside
wouldn't follow her shock took a moment
to calm herself she set herself down on
a leather chair in front of the dark
wood desk that filled most of the space
in the office it had belonged to one Dr
Dwyer according to the computer that
stood atop the desk which shock began to
hack into once again using her key card
cracking device after about a half an
hour working through some very
sophisticated security software she
eventually managed to force her way into
the computer and started clicking
through its files the first thing she
uncovered in a folder that was
conveniently labeled important was an
email from the o5 command to the
director of this abandoned former
Foundation site along with other
high-ranking members of personnel the
subject simply read farewell in the
email 05-7 mentioned that the last
number of Escape ships had successfully
launched from site 101 and arrived at
Colony station
it seemed that some kind of war was
imminent and would ravage the entire
Earth leaving nothing behind so in their
Infinite Wisdom the SCP Foundation had
been using its vast resources to
evacuate its Personnel off-world
meanwhile the Personnel at site 101
would stamp their posts perhaps to
repopulate or rebuild the Earth after
the impending War had passed that email
had been sent in the year 2217 a whole
18 years before shock had arrived at
this facility hoping to rate it the next
email in the folder was headed with the
words Intruder since just under a month
before a para Foundation security
Personnel officer Sanchez and meche had
happened across a breach in the
ventilation system according to their
reports it looked as if someone or
something had forced its way in with
some kind of metal Implement shortly
after a third officer officer Peterson
failed to respond to a radio check
seemingly going missing security had
been advised to travel in groups and
engage any unknown entity with lethal
Force something had made its way into
the facility and it had arrived just
before shock did uneasy still not sure
what had happened here the dimension
hopping scavenger read on the third and
final email entry had been sent the day
after the last this time security had a
better idea of what they were up against
surveillance footage from within the
facility had revealed the Intruder to be
none other than
scp-049 it had claimed the lives of
multiple security officers with two of
them confirmed to have been instances of
scp-049-2 being from a different
Universe however shock had no idea what
an scp-049 was nor did she like the idea
of being trapped with one now in case
you like shock haven't heard of the
infamous plague doctor then here's a
brief bit of context on scp-049 a tall
figure shrouded in Long Black robes a
hood over his head with only a white
beaked mask protrude from underneath
these aren't just parts of his attire
though the SCP Foundation discovered
that all of the pieces of scp-049's
outfit are part of his physical body
made out of muscle and bone the blank
doctor's primary goal is to find those
he deems to be infected with something
he refers to as the pestilence if he
ever senses this Affliction he will
attempt to make direct skin contact with
the person carrying it
scp-049's touch is lethal killing anyone
who comes into contact with him in a
matter of minutes you might think that's
all the plague doctor does going from
person to person killing them by a touch
but you would be wrong once he has
killed the victim scp-049 then begins
performing a crude outdated form of
surgery on their corpse using equipment
he produces from his mysterious medical
bag he injects a number of unknown
chemicals into a person's carcass
eventually turning them into an instance
of
scp-049-2 in other words a zombie and
that's exactly what it had done to at
least two of the site 101 security
officers when shock delve further into
the computer examining some security
footage not only did she watch a
monstrosity in a shredded security
uniform shambling through a corridor but
there was something else following it a
figure completely clad in Black robes
its face shrouded behind an eerie beaked
mask shock decided her best course of
action was to find out as much as she
could about scp-049 then using the
facility's security cameras to figure
out the quickest route to find any
propulsion Tech that the foundation
might have left lying around she
familiarized herself with the
foundation's extensive file on scp-049
learning what the plague doctor could do
the part shock found to be particularly
unsettling was knowing that the entity
could shut down an organism's biological
functions whenever it made direct skin
contact best to try and avoid him she
told herself studying the camera feeds
shock noticed scp-05 9-2s that had all
been the former staff of this facility
they didn't seem to move around much
unless provoked all she had to do was
make it through the corridors to a door
labeled propulsion testing without the
dash twos noticing her sounds easy in
theory and it would have been easier in
practice if there weren't currently
eight of the zombies standing in her
path to the testing room with a tight
grip around her Blaster shot bolted from
the office barreling at full Sprint down
the corridor she already knew from
watching the cameras that the first the
scp-049-2s was around the nearest Corner
opening fire she went speeding past its
remains as it turned into little more
than a smoldering pile on the floor
around the next Corner were another two
of the creatures dispatched as quickly
as the first with a bright blue crackle
of the energy weapon so far so good but
shock was already anticipating seeing a
group of five
scp-049-2s huddled together the next
obstacle in her way sure enough she had
navigated her way through the facility's
hallways towards them making sure she
had the element of surprise on her side
she blasted the oncoming mob of zombies
screaming as they were struck by the
blue light of her Blaster only to vanish
vaporize forever all except for the
fifth and final
scp-049-2 instance shock had fired her
fifth shot too soon missing the last of
the creatures she waited for it to close
the distance between them hoping for a
closer Target but the monstrosity
knocked the gun from her hands shock
pulled a fusion bomb from her bag
wrapping the unstable energy cell in her
coat she let the creature grab the
makeshift bomb from her picking up her
weapon and running as the bomb detonated
exhausted she reached the propulsion
testing room injured after her fight
with the dash too shock had hoped her
troubles were over and for a moment they
certainly seemed to be she had stumbled
across a motherload of tech modified
reality anchors and all kinds of
equipment that would be perfect Salvage
but then from the Shadows something new
stepped forward the plague doctor
himself shock Drew her Blaster again and
pulled the trigger but the weapon was
spent sparking in her hands as it failed
to fire Frozen she stared at scp-049 and
it stared back lowering her weapon shock
tried to calmly introduce herself to the
looming cloaked anomaly I'm shocked nice
to meet you you're rather these people
call you scp-49 right sure did a bang-up
job of carrying everyone in here from
the looks of things for a moment they
talked scp-049 had heard the foundation
Personnel at site 101 talking of being
the last men on Earth and made its way
into the facility to save them as he put
it ridding them of the pestilence shock
explained that the rest of the planet's
surface outside had been severely
irradiated and that there was no one
living up top anymore all while sneakily
sliding pieces of expensive looking Tech
into her bag
scp-049 argued that there were still
people left on Earth but site 42 housed
the very last remnants of humanity but
they had been Untouched by disease these
they were pure but shock didn't care one
bit instead she made a move nobody would
have expected she offered the plague
doctor a lift the Mariachi's Merchants
would be coming back for her soon and
their ship was able to take them
anywhere in the Multiverse after
pondering for a moment
scp-049 asked to be taken with them to
find where the rest of the sick were
unwilling to accept his work was done as
long as you agree to keep your hands to
yourself shock told him as a gray orb
appeared in the room hovering above the
floor without touching the ceiling it
was time to leave being on SCP-173
detail isn't easy these duties of strict
observation fall on a bi-weekly basis
when scp-173's enclosure needs to be
cleaned the reddish brown substance on
the floor is a natural output of SCP-173
a combination of feces and blood while
the foundation has put up with a lot of
depraved behavior from its scps it it
draws the line at poor hygiene they
routinely send in a crew of three
d-class personnel to clean up the mess
but the bigger chore isn't the scrubbing
and mopping at all but rather keeping
SCP-173 docile to do so the line of
sight must not be broken at any time
with SCP-173 Personnel assigned to enter
the container are instructed to alert
one another before blinking if this
protocol is not followed
SCP-173 attacks by snapping the neck at
the base of the skull it is at its core
a high-stakes staring contest the crew
is intelligently divided into their
tasks only one of them actually has
janitorial duties and even then the
moppers most relevant skill isn't even
related to cleaning at all his greatest
strength must be his ability to trust
other people as he takes his mop to the
floor he hands over his life to his crew
who protect him with their focus and
attention on SCP-173 it is without a
doub out one of the cruelest and most
stressful jobs anyone could ever have
but not every horror story is found in
the trenches of Terror those with mops
on the front lines have their work cut
out for them but even the researchers
with their warm lab coats and boring
bureaucratic obligations aren't safe
from danger this is the story of Jake
skull a researcher who for reasons we
will tactfully tease you with until the
videos witty end has been reassigned to
SCP-173 director Fordham brought the bad
news like a bag of coal you're being
reassigned he said with a slight smirk
on his face continuing to be preoccupied
with his paperwork as if this news was
secondary to what he was doing right
there and then but it wasn't secondary
to Jack skull it was the center of their
life no not even just the center it was
The Sinner peripheral and outer bounds
of their life their assignments were
everything
and everything was about to change a
pregnant silence followed the
announcement Jake's skull couldn't find
a response and they weren't even sure
there was one to be found no matter how
deep they dug what came out wasn't as
much of a retort as a reaction that
involuntary bodily response to events
that weren't expected that awkward and
Afraid muttering of fear and confusion
ah I
what I am I'm being where uh I I'm to be
reassigned is that what you're saying
research your skull blinked a few times
confused their feet sunk into the deep
forest green shag on the floor a
spectrum of thoughts cascaded through
their mind as they searched harder and
harder for a reason digging deeper and
deeper only to find another Treasure
Chest full of nothing is my work not
sufficient on SCP director Fordham
looked up and gave them the fixed
pointed stair they'd grown to dread over
the past six months of course not Jake I
recognize what you've done and we want
to put you somewhere I feel you deserve
and serve the foundation of course we're
putting you on a very important and
special object again Fordham gave that
smirk that damn smirk sure his words and
tone presented themselves as the truth
but his face said otherwise the devious
positioning of his lip suggested that
there was a layer of sin subtext to his
speech but Jake schole couldn't pick up
on the cues there's no room to read
someone else's poker face when all of
your attention is on the crappy hand
you've just been dealt Jake skull's eyes
fell to the desk reassigned the word
rang like church bells why God their
work with scp-3872 as a Consulting
chemist was going slowly to be truthful
but they didn't think it was to the
point that they needed reassignment ah
all right which project am I assigned to
the time between the question and the
answer was the longest of Jake's life
the uncertainty felt like an eternity
Fordham tapped a few symbols accessing
skull's profile and added an entry in
their security clearance he hastily
swiped away all the other files listed
and turned back to face skull you have
access to it now please get on the first
plane to site 19. your dormitory
contents are already packed up Jake
reached into their pocket to check the
notification on their cell phone
scp-3872 file removed
scp-2593 file removed
SCP-173 file added they turned around
and walked slowly through the corridors
towards the Transportation Hub on the
outskirts of the site they open the file
on their phone and quickly scanned the
oddly phrased report attempting to make
sense of what they were reading skull's
eyebrows raised to the heavens as they
noticed the timestamp on containment
SCP-173 was one of the first one of the
few objects that the foundation came to
possess through some organization or
another without losing its information
they tried their best to remain
optimistic in their interpretation of
these new life events and for a moment
they thought this might be a good thing
for me swiping down they came to the
section about assigned researchers the
people whose steps they would be
following in and where were those steps
leading them the list was impressive
from Dr draki to Dr bright these people
were all legends in their own right and
so if they could just follow their
footsteps they reason they would end
their journey in a good place they
imagine their new career path straight
to the top of this mountain of success
maybe they would become the face of the
foundation maybe they would accomplish
so much that they'd had a statue erected
in their honor that people travel far
and wide to visit and take pictures with
maybe this would be a good thing they
wanted to think I need the first plane
to site 19. they said with confidence
I've been reassigned and so Jake skull
took to the air and clung to the stream
as long as they could but no matter how
heavy a sleeper reality shakes everyone
awake eventually six years later Jake
skull could hear the years pass but not
only could they hear it they could feel
it their body was decaying in a way
inconsistent with our biological
understanding of age
SCP-173 the legendary object the first
the original the statue it was chipping
away at the soul of Jake's skull it was
carving a statue of its own hacking at
Stone until it was nothing and that's
what Jake's Scholl felt like nothing it
was torture when they arrived they
quickly reviewed the research materials
every word had become burned into their
memory all 233 words of them the
additional research materials turned out
to be a few scribbled Pages by board
researchers a few had made hypotheses
that it all turned out to be nonsense
there was a locked filing cabinet but
every time skull requested it be opened
maintenance told them that the control
room was designated low priority and
they would get to it eventually over the
past six years Jake's skull had made 18
separate transfer requests they wanted
out but all of them had been denied it
was as if they were in high school again
asking dates to prom and getting hit
with no thank yous feeling none of the
politeness backed into their syntax
understanding only the brutal reality of
the phrase no they were stuck here
technically a level 3 staff now but
without any rights to view or work on
any other objects they were given a
promotion but it withheld all the perks
and benefits that come with it they were
stuck in a loop of pats on the back
people extended them their hand but it
was always with an empty Palm giving
them nothing to hold on to but a gesture
they were assigned a staff of four three
d-class all of which were older men and
a lazy level 2 security officer who
slouched in this office chair meeting
the bare minimum requirements to be
considered a living human being the
d-class were all quite docile they came
in once a week mopped the floor mumbled
clear to each other and left they lived
within this exact structure no new days
became an unspoken motto the these
recurring 24 hours pass slowly if there
were no clocks to prove the passing of
time they would have every reason to
believe it had frozen over but
occasionally ever so occasionally the
day would deviate just slightly they'd
hear something a scrape and the sounds
of movement Jake would flip open the
observation ports on the double concrete
lock and examine SCP-173 but Jake could
take offense to such language examining
might be the wrong word more accurately
they would just look at it because there
was nothing to examine there was nothing
to observe
SCP-173 was already understood Michael
Jordan doesn't take a microscope to the
ball every time he plans to dribble he
knows every detail of it by heart his
fingertips know the grooves his hand-eye
coordination knows how to control it his
right arms built in apt for physics
knows exactly how much force to put into
each shot and at what trajectory to aim
we are told learn something new every
day but the truth is there comes a day
when the learning stops when we know all
that we will ever know and this felt
true to Jake they understood
SCP-173 there was nothing more for them
to see it was just concrete Reebok and
some spray paint that was it and that
was all that it would ever be there was
nothing to find nothing to determine
nothing for the researcher to research
their job was done but they kept having
to work it their identity no longer fit
but they kept having to put it on each
and every morning when Jake first got
there they collected samples of the
concrete some of the rebars some spray
paint they were determined to find
something worthy of research after four
weeks they'd gotten sick of getting no
replies from admin and they cracked the
locks on the filing cabinet finding the
research notes of all the previous
researchers all the legendary doctors
notes turned out to be Doodles and
random to-do lists which had nothing to
do with the object after six weeks they
gave up on taking samples after eight
weeks they brought a Game Boy after 10
they started bringing in anything they
could to pass the time a yo-yo a
collection of short stories a packet of
hot sauce they felt bad throwing away a
piece of string to cut off circulation
to their index finger for no other
reason than to make sure they were still
a human relying on blood oh yes Jake's
skull was bored so very bored they
thought if anyone could bring the phrase
bored to death to fruition it would be
them these days they shuffled in and
waved at the guard and sat down at their
little control room where there was a
terminal which by the way didn't have an
internet connection and tried to stay
sane fast forward a few years and Jake
barely fit into his chair to clarify no
they did not purchase a new tiny chair
out of boredom they got fat out of
boredom their life brought them no joy
and so what they couldn't get from
living they searched for in eating but
there was no fulfillment to be found at
the center of the Tootsie Pop Jake stood
with a grunt as the light came on and
the 3D class were escorted to the
control room with the mops and buckets
in tow thanks Jimmy was the only
conversation they had with the new
security staff the Old Guard had retired
some time in the eighth year honestly
Jay couldn't even remember the d-class
had gotten older too most of them now
gray-haired but still assigned to the
project the security guard walked over
and thumbed towards the break room Hey
Jake I'm gonna get coffee if anything
happens seal the door you know the drill
just keep an eye on the DS Jake buzzed
the doors open and stood inside the door
frame keeping their eyes on the Statue
most of the time but but wandering over
the containment chamber a long time ago
they might have been concerned but the
d-classes they worked with weren't very
violent frankly they had worked with
these men long enough that they extended
a small measure of trust all them did
their jobs without complaining and never
had made a mistake in 10 years while the
years of repetition wore them out the
job itself didn't even feel like labor
they had perfected the art of the
staring contest they were confident and
they had reason to be as the years went
on although they collected no new data
on SCP-173 they did collect evidence
evidence that they were capable of
containing it while they learned nothing
new of importance about SCP-173 they
learned about themselves they learned
that they were a good crew and it was
because of this confidence even if
rightfully earned that success crumbled
when in a room with SCP-173 you have to
assume everything will go wrong because
anything can go wrong and eventually it
will and when that time comes you have
to be prepared procedure said Jake had
to have someone armed in the room with
any d-class Jake looked down at their
head double checked the pistol there
they knew how to use it but figured he
never would have to draw it the routine
cleaning began Claire Claire Claire it
was the same old same old until suddenly
it wasn't clear oh no I think I'm having
a snap what hey hey Nick are you snap oh
God no I don't want to snap Jake's eyes
shut up as the statue stood inches away
its green eyes stared directly into
their soul in their periphery Jay could
see the 3D class with their head turned
at odd angles Jake desperately reached
out for the Emergency containment button
on the wall they hadn't ever had to use
it and it was supposed to be easy to
find but of course it wasn't they were
called the manual saying move your hand
anywhere along the right hand wall the
button takes up most of the wall it will
seal off the containment chamber and
SCP-173 from breaching containment they
moved their hand exactly how their
memory of the manual instructor
but it wasn't there there was nothing to
press there was nothing to save them
Jake's hands grew desperate and their
eyes began to water just as they started
to close a last thought crossed their
mind move your hand anywhere along the
left hand wall the button takes up most
of the wall it will seal off the
containment chamber and SCP-173 from
breaching containment of course a
classic mix-up 50 50 chances never
favored the flustered their
fight-or-flight instincts were
contradicting each other was reaching
for a button fighting or was it fighting
they were in their head deep in trenches
of overthinking finally they regained
their composure their hand darted out to
the left and they started to push down
on the button the red of the emergency
button filled their Vision as the green
eyes of SCP-173 slipped just barely out
of snap director Kinsley stood outside
of the meeting room a few minutes before
the weekly briefing in the site 2117
administrative wing for them do you
remember Jake's skull oh yeah I sure do
just got a report from 19. looks like
there was a breach and they bit it
Fordham waved off a few colleagues who
were about to enter the meeting room his
conversation with director Kinsley
wasn't over he went on to tell him that
he was just about to approve Jake's
skull's transfer after all these years
Jake had been sending requests to leave
SCP-173 their wish was about to be
granted but instead they were reassigned
to the Grave what a cruel twist isn't it
that is of course if it were actually
true Fordham gave his patented smirk
just kidding the only researchers to
ever get out of that post needed friends
in very high places scroll to his
detriment did not so what exactly did
skull do to deserve this it is known
that those who are sent to a cp-173 have
made mistakes if you disrespect your
boss you might be reassigned to SCP-173
if you don't follow Foundation policy
you might
into SCP-173 if you leak information to
the public you might be reassigned to
SCP-173 if you are Jake scroll however
it doesn't take quite as much so I will
pose the question once more what
horrible thing could Jake have done
could they have been plotting to help an
array of scps Escape could they have
been smuggling dangerous equipment from
the lab and selling it on the black
market could they have somehow been
responsible for every casualty and
Foundation history or could it have been
something much much smaller like
occasionally parking in their boss's
favorite spot on site 217 a lot you must
understand which doesn't have a signed
parking the SCP foundation's most famous
anomalies are legendary from the
notorious 682 and its Acid Bath to
pesterbot some scps are instantly
recognizable from only an image or a few
sentences of information but the SCP
Foundation also encompasses endless
universes and possibilities and that
means endless variations on these iconic
anomalies maybe in one reality 173 is
simply one of many terrifying statues or
perhaps 682 is an heir to the infamous
infernal Scarlet King and of course
there are other versions of the
foundation itself too from Worlds where
they are known as the foundation
Incorporated and seek only to line their
own Pockets to realities where the
foundation is a Theocratic organization
holding a line after the apocalypse what
follows is a peek into one such
alternate universe and their version of
one of the foundation's most mysterious
and enigmatic anomalies can you guess
what it is some people think that the
foundation operations are limited to
Land Air and sea to some extent they're
right while the vast majority of
anomalies exist on Earth the o5 council
knows that space is infinite and that
means infinite possibility for other
anomalies that's why the foundation has
sights on the moon on space stations
orbiting the Earth even installations on
Venus and Mars there are even rumors
that the foundation retains their very
own small Fleet of space shuttles to
move some of the particularly dangerous
anomalies off planet where they pose no
risk to society but space goes well
beyond just our neighboring planets the
foundation also invests heavily into
exploring deep space so that they might
find anomalies like the hateful star
before they pose a danger rather than
after to this end they've sent a small
army of space probes equipped with
Advanced sensors and rudimentary
artificial intelligence in every
direction away from our planet to scout
for potential anomalies but the issue is
that sometimes the probes actually end
up encountering anomalies such is the
Curious Case of probe H9 which
disappeared under mysterious
circumstances while scouting a potential
anomaly in a completely empty Barren
region of deep space the foundation
assigns an internal investigator to the
case one Joffrey Davies who schedules a
sit-down with Isaac miles the chief
technician in charge of the probe and
many others under Foundation command
probe h9's AI system known as ph9 was in
communication with Miles throughout its
strange Journey right up until the end
the logs requested by Davies are read
out at first it seems like a routine
signal ph9 calls into base to inform
them that it has detected a signal but
not just any signal an emergency SOS
signal coming from deep in an otherwise
empty quadrant of space despite having
two sensors the probe is unable to find
anything in that area with its telescope
miles authorizes the probe to change its
route to pass through where the signal
is coming from and pH 9 confirms that it
will arrive at the source of the SOS in
399 hours or 17 days the two men
exchange some words miles explains he
does not contact his superiors because
protocol means they need visual
confirmation before sending a space
shuttle in and pH 9's telescope couldn't
find anything even though the signal was
confirmed to be human miles didn't want
to break protocol and let the probe go
in alone investor Davies begrudgingly
agrees that it was a smart decision and
they move on an hour after ph9 entered
the quadrant of space where the signal
was coming from miles is still waiting
for a report finally he contacts ph9
which informs him that it is still
unable to get a look at where the signal
is coming from even though it is so
close it will arrive in four hours miles
confused by how this is possible asks it
for its readings on its weight and
gravity the investigator asks him why he
wanted this information and Miles
explains that the probe passed through
some kind of event horizon the probe was
continuing to move into the quadrant but
for some reason looked like it it wasn't
this happens when something enters a
black hole but if it was a black hole pH
9 would have been unable to transmit and
completely destroyed some kind of
anomaly has trapped ph9 inside its
massive well of gravity when miles again
radioed into ph9 the probe had a strange
response that it would pass by the
signal Source in four hours the exact
same as last time something was
obviously wrong with the probe as well
over four hours had passed and the probe
signal meant it should be right next to
the source miles decides the probe is
faulty and assigns probe j4 to meet it
and take it to a repair facility but
when probe j4 arrives ph9 can't see it
ph9 can't even detect it using any other
kind of sensor but it does detect the
same SOS signal and against all logic it
is still 4 hours away pH 9 tries to
offer its coordinates but it can't in
fact it says that its current
coordinates are outside of euclidean
space like so many non-euclidean
anomalies the foundation deals with
Miles can't decide whether ph9 has
fallen into a gravity well or something
much much worse has happened and pH 9
holds position miles explains that then
he called his superiors to let them know
the deeply strange events occurring in
relation to their probes but the closest
team was a week away by the time they
arrived on scene to investigate it was
all over they couldn't advise on what to
do about the pro there were far too many
unknowns in relation to space anomalies
and so Miles simply told ph9 to continue
on its course and report back every hour
because there was nothing else to do and
nothing to lose the last hour of reports
are where things suddenly take a sharp
turn ph9 calls into command saying that
it is suddenly detecting a massive
object almost a million kilometers away
from it the signal source is still four
hours away but this new object is some
sort of planetoid fourteen hundred
kilometers across and Incredibly light
for its size for comparison the asteroid
that killed the dinosaurs was 10
kilometers across ph9 moves to get a
better look but its analysis keeps
failing because it's getting closer not
just that but getting closer impossibly
quickly in a minute it's suddenly 400
000 kilometers away 30 seconds later and
it's 250 000 kilometers and showing no
signs of slowing down before miles can
explain why this is impossible the probe
reports that it is about to collide with
the planetoid the last message it
transmits before all communication sees
is a single image from its telescope
showing whatever was about to crash into
the probe a massive blurry white sphere
completely featureless against the
starless backdrop the men are confused
neither of them know what this image
means by all evidence the probe was
rocketing through empty space way too
fast for anything to catch up to it and
yet something obviously he did something
was chasing the probe they agree it
wasn't a rogue planet and Davies
dismisses miles with some words of
advice to start taking his vacation time
and head on home after a final
debriefing turning to his Aid he
instructs the agent to file the
interview and completely quarantine the
quadrant of space making sure nothing
enters and exits and ominously to ensure
that Miles gets processed the foundation
does not leave Loose Ends untied after
all have you managed to figure out what
anomaly that this is a parallel version
of something going into a contained
endless space towards a human signal at
the bottom that seems to never be
getting closer before suddenly being
consumed by a blurry white thing that's
right it's the infamous and notorious
scp-087 the endless staircase many of us
are familiar with this anomaly we should
be considering how dangerous and ominous
it is to even season Foundation veterans
a metal door in the back of a high
school campus leading down and down and
down endlessly into an Inky black void
where a bone chilling weeping and crying
of a baby coming from the bottom teasing
people to try and find the source at
first the foundation were only
interested in finding out where exactly
this crying was coming from but soon
they realized just like miles that
something was very very wrong the first
explorer they sent in an older man had
gone down only a few flights when he
heard the crying and sobbing of a baby
200 meters away spooked he was
instructed against his protest to
continue descending the dark damn
staircase almost 30 flights down he
suddenly realized the next Landing
wasn't empty like the others in front of
him was a grotesque parody of a head an
owl Blaster white face with no mouth or
nostrils and blank empty white eyes just
floating feet above the ground round
staring at that thing despite his Terror
the subject began to approach just
before it suddenly shot up the stairs
going right for his face by the time he
reached the top of the stairs after a
panicked hysterical run he collapsed
face down on the concrete the
foundation's following attempts fared a
little better in one the d-class had
descended almost 100 flights of stairs
when he encountered the face doing
nothing they simply stared at each other
right up until the face again shot up
toward him he turned and ran screaming
all the way up the stairs unlike the
first subject he didn't manage to make
it out of scp-087 before he collapsed
his heart stopped and the foundation
prepared to send in a recovery Mission
until suddenly his heartbeat restarted
but with an abnormal unnatural heartbeat
the subject's lymph form then calmly
walked up the stairs to the exit closed
the door sat down and fell into a
vegetative state slipping into a
permanent coma in the next ever
everything seemed to be going well until
the subject entered a strange hole in
the landing with a light at the bottom
shrugging she continues all the way to
the 500th landing almost two kilometers
below ground when she decides to go back
up against orders turning around she is
shocked by the presence of the face only
a few inches behind her head it had been
following her down those stairs for who
knows how long and this time it's not
staring at her it's staring at the
researchers behind the screens of her
camera in Terror she runs down the
stairs looking behind her after several
hundred feet only to see the face still
barely a foot behind her staring into
the camera with a dead-eyed glare by the
time she realizes that the sound of the
crying is getting closer she's already
stumbled and fallen down into the hard
concrete knocking herself unconscious
the last thing the researchers see
before the camera cuts out is the face
making piercing eye contact with them
and of course the info Infamous fourth
exploration whatever occurred in the
final descent into scp-087 was so
concerning to the foundation that they
opted to seal all logs of it and expunge
all the data we may never truly know
what lies at the bottom of the staircase
or what the face wants from people who
enter its territory just like how we may
never know what exactly probe H9 was
being signaled by or what the massive
object moving at the speed of light
directly into the probe was and just
like how the foundation cleaned up all
the remains of exploration 4. the
foundation also plans to make sure miles
cannot tell anyone about this strange
deep space anomaly now check out
scp-1548 the star the hateful for
another space-based anomaly or for more
from the depths of scp-087 Watch The
Secret at the bottom of
scp-087 explained